my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hear ye hear ye hear ye
round what's going on talk to me how we
doing out here
casket repair hustle and motivate punk
show my guy
what's going on [ __ ] j what's going on
talk to me what's going on out here how
y'all doing
death mobile lethal papa going on
flame lords of gamer.net in the building
my man flame salute
what's going on chillin how i'm shouting
out here talk to the people
[Music]
um how are we doing are we doing
alex psx asked the multi-player worker
what it was like moments before the
footage released
oh yeah i got you i got this
what else we got what's up
let's go i like that
i like that nando soups
max the lazy on taco what's going on
only full set okay
excuse me when i'm eating no doubt thank
you bro we appreciate you appreciate you
salute to the lord yeah man we got a big
one man that's the phone these are the
ones that's fun
so you already know patrick will be in
the building you know i'm saying kane'll
be pulling up soon
saul will be pulling up soon yeah i got
me a little um
he said what's tasty yeah i got me a
little crescent a little croissant with
the chicken and
um you know what i'm saying chicken and
cheese getting it getting it ready
you know what i'm saying oh muscle
hustle say he can't hear you addict
also what's up okay y'all here addict
make sure make sure y'all can hear him
maybe he didn't hear you that one time i
was talking
let me
chad let us know if you get attic but
talk to me everyone get a book addict
talking through his tcl
pong says no no addict uh
that's what they say they
yeah desktop audio is not yeah it's not
it's it's me because desktop audio ain't
coming so
you're absolutely right oh i know what
it is okay device good test good catch
chat
well let's see one second
i should be coming through the um
all right talk to the people at it
attempt
number two number two yeah i think i see
you coming through now level's coming
through what about
now y'all cuz she's coming up on my side
you know what i'm saying all right what
about keep talking
keep talking cause i i i i can hear him
yeah i can see you i could he
you can hear you on the joint yeah there
you go there you go good
catch man almost messed the show up
that's why my checks are important thank
you
good call good catch right there jiggy j
thank you so um
oh nam what's going on brother thank you
for support i'll be seeing you in the
home
in the chat so look we're gonna get
patrick up in here you know what i'm
saying king will be
rolling through and we're gonna have
some fun we got that halo
multiplayer yeah so we hyped man so we
will see y'all
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
mic check number two with attic before
we start attic talk to the people
just testing my mic to see how it sounds
you can you can ignore us
just let him know if he sounds uh yeah i
hear him if he sounds
better okay
okay it sounds better yeah adding listen
to himself alright he's good
we'll be right back hustle said loud and
clear no doubt
[Music]
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i'm addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
messaging people on aim check my
[Music]
dog thing very loyal but i ain't gonna
hold you i ain't here to boy you ain't
gotta say it i'm embarrassed for you
i've always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lord's
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and had this be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i'm addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame
still i'll be running collecting them
rings you just a target when i'm in the
range i was the hardest to start
regardless
of people on aim check my vocals follow
on twitter but i'm anti-social love my
city but i'm still by coastal
[Music]
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing that
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on the song with
me that's understandable i kill a beat
and they want to compare me to freddie
and jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them rings you just a target when i'm in
the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people check my vocals
on twitter but i'm anti-social my city
but i'm still by coastal
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lord's
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and had this be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game
just be original y'all so dramatical i
know it's random but i'm addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that
a shout out to everybody combat talk was
gonna go up yesterday but we had a lot
of things happening in the realm so that
stuff could not happen
but let me tell you something you had a
lomo change yeah it was it was a tale of
two fights yeah lomo chako
versus uh his comeback fight uh it was
short versus tall and you had javonte
tank davis versus mario barrios notice
how i didn't say
a lomachenko's uh opponent there's a
reason why
all right so you had uh tall i mean
short versus toilet you had tank davis
going up two weight classes
to fight the champion there and yeah
lomo chenko staying in his weight class
uh uh uh uh a non-descript all right so
lomachenko had an excuse for his loss
and you know
um apparently you know he had a shoulder
injury the reason why he
uh lost to lopez anyway
in typical fashion lomachenko goes out
and he uh wins this fight by tko
on to the real fight tank davis versus
mario barrios mario barrios goes in and
mario barrios does exactly what a
champion is supposed to do
he fights this dude down and tank is
fighting back
10 comes from behind gives him a tko in
the 11th round
and it is actually let me leave him back
in
he is utterly amazing i got to give tank
much props because he fought the bigger
taller man in his weight class he went
up two weight classes to fight him
and it was something to be seen much
respect
on the young mike tyson he has the most
powerful punches in boxing today
pound
with him with that young champion so
he's a champion in the two divisions god
bless
we're going to get to this uh stuff a
little bit later see y'all i just want
to give you all the exclusive before we
started you know
nick said he could always get his boxing
mma updates from king david he don't
need espn
thank you we'll see you tomorrow patrick
has arrived so we're gonna uh
should do some mic testing and we'll get
started in a minute
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i'll be eating these rappers
but that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
they don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i'm addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when
[Music]
um
[Music]
a proclamation
i'ma just chill and watch so many snacks
in the attic i wanted to chill with the
pack and be like a young wolf but then
they would mistake me for addict if i
can imagine it's cool to give you some
advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that
option you're gonna be single player
like siren you're gonna get tossed in
the bushes by king david
royalty ain't not a pretender
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar to a knee bender i gotta be me
though
i know it's my destiny word to cognito
who cares if you fly if you steal a
mosquito you swear you ain't something
but really
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news
even if you really was that you can't
never still be the king of the statues
since the juvenile i've been cursed with
a curse to be musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in the crucible was it and
nothing is cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle
on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
before we actually start mike check mike
checked
talk to the people real quick yeah we
gotta see levels that's good because we
had a little issue
before we're gonna make a little bit of
levels a little bit levels exactly
and we are live
welcome to the iron lords podcast l
l c we're gonna put that on there
[Laughter]
episode number 214 it's another glorious
sunday we're back at the round table on
the lord's day
i'm extremely excited about our special
guest and we've got
three four three industries
halo infinite multiplayer windows 11
with xbox and the latest
xcloud server updates to discuss so we
go get right into it
i want to introduce a lord whose
contagious passion for the technical
design of video games
is only matched by its razor sharp focus
and getting to the heart
of what we all enjoy having fun while
playing these games
introducing the multiplayer system
designer for the iconic halo infinite
franchise
and mission design contributor to halo 5
guardians
the pride of 343 and xbox game studios
and still one half of the most
adorable halo destiny power couple
in the game
[Laughter]
live from washington and guided them to
make his debut
into the realm of the lords mommy
lord patrick wren of 343 industries
how're we doing sir
good i i don't know how to respond to an
intro like that that was amazing
i figured
[Laughter]
what's been going on in the world i know
you guys probably busy and everything
with the crutch but
have you been had a chance to even play
any other video games
any other video games oh you know here
and there especially like
the last couple weekends making sure
that you know we
take a break here and there especially
with the heat wave we have
you know trying to stay cool so yeah
absolutely well that was good man glad
you
had some time to take out for us and uh
man we're looking forward to having you
talking some halo and all the thing
that's going on with you
but um before we do it i want to get
that over to solve right quick because
you know the superchats are coming in
and he has to
set the rules of engagement here today
first up we have tony bryant with the
five dollar super chat congrats lords
ready for a fantastic show thank you so
much my brother
then we got [ __ ] j check the five
dollar super
good morning lords excited for halo
let's get sarah bond on here as well
game pass game pass game bats oh they
ready they're ready
and then we have flame with the five
dollars we chat good morning realm
and to the 343 royalty thank you and to
your team for the show on the 13th still
emotional
good luck thank you so much now the
disclaimer time
ladies and gentlemen uh as lord
wrens uh time is limited any
super-tastic come in
once we reach the interview part portion
of the show
uh we'll just hold on to the end of the
show because obviously we want to
respect this time we have a limited time
so we want to be able to talk to him as
much
as we can about halo multiplayer so
thank you so much we appreciate that
so you already know we got the four
horsemen of gaming
those original lords of the realm here
at the round table with those updated
time sets here because patrick has
limited time
intros my girls with the most
my brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror lord of his own
world
and the heart of the young wolf my man
lord addict how are we doing sir he's in
the bushes
yeah he muted
he probably had to step away for a
second he definitely would have done
that but we will get
at it you know what i'm saying shout out
to one and i had to get one away real
quick what's good let's go shout out to
salvo on that staycation you already
know
the staycation that ain't happening it's
not happening no
one but of course oh there he is he's
back he's back
attic you got your intro but you you get
the comment
oh my bad i had to get something to
drink my throats
kind of messed up yeah you're good
appreciate uh
you know lord patrick for coming on man
we got a good show for you guys i i
ain't going to talk a whole whole lot
this this this episode so
so uh we're going to leave it all on the
king to do the interrupting person
[Music]
and of course we have our most technical
gaming lord
the solo gamer who lives for the single
player selfish experience
and also the sastradamus the lord
of clarity and patreon of the iron bank
definitely yesterday
mommy how are we doing sir doing well
dude we're doing well i just want to
thank our amazing you know our amazing
chat and community for slandering me
last week
for wearing my coke bottle glasses you
know
they just look kind of crazy though man
your astute older gentleman glasses
my i can't see a damn thing
when wifey said what happened to song
i was seeing people in the chat be like
i didn't know he was this blind
so exactly so now i i found my my
reading glasses and i have my contacts
and my reading glasses down just to
appease all of you
thank you i appreciate you doing well
um not much gaming this week i did
finish uh
castlevania on netflix which is amazing
and i
finished invincible as well if you
haven't watched invincible yet
go watch it yeah very good
deadly sentence tomorrow so that's what
i'm waiting for yeah
okay i caught castlevania but i it
didn't captivate me like the second
season really
like that second season i don't know why
but that
no doubt and of course we have the
incredible hulk of this
aka the xs gamer
the prophet of xbox king of the statues
who demands nothing less than that
premium experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
beloved little kid how you doing sir i'm
doing a whole lot better today llc
fantastic
y'all already know chaos kos is up right
there shout out to my man and send me
that statue
uh we'll talk about that later that is
one of my favorite statues
what's going on no that's not another
series that's that's the statue
that i got um from one of our great
developer friends that we will not say
on the show right now
yeah um but it's a beautiful statue i
love it the reason why i'm talking so
fast because time is sensitive
i've been playing a dragon's quest i am
frustrated frustrated but i did my raid
um
and shout out to the ashton one ashley
luca
welcome to the clan yeah she got a
chance to you know hang out with the
king and realize you know that uh
button down king is different from
button up king king
podcast but um we we had a great time uh
she had a very smooth raid
you know we actually really played
destiny people and you know outright is
i'm still doing carry so if you uh need
any help with outright just hit me up
i'll take you through that's my time i'm
gonna break totally okay
you want me to read this yeah yeah i'm
gonna break we gotta break okay yeah
okay so i'm gonna read these last two we
got m p five dollars which had this
round table is the
ultimate xbox achievement thank you sir
and we have family of course gaming
forte five dollar super chat
so proud of you guys first becoming
official media
now llc love all the work you guys put
in and as always
[Laughter]
okay you must go ahead and grab that the
absolute
last one ladies and gentlemen please
until later thank you for appreciation
kdk five dollars super chat i know
patrick was laughing like yeah yeah i
said that already twice
80k five dollar super chat happy sunday
lords i always look forward to the lord
say thank you for the great time every
week hashtag
praise the lord thank you so much we got
400
um in the chat please hit that like
share it out right now
listen you're about to get some gems
from three four three
and i'm telling you right now you're
waiting for this
you're all excited for this share that
out to your friends yes
wake him up right now because if he's
asleep he needs to be up watching lord
patrick's here man taking time out dave
of course we have the gaming ninja
himself the shinobi
lord cognito spread that realness in a
roman iop not telling what you want to
hear but what you need to hear i'll make
a quick shout out to ebon to shout out
to the last word
friday was amazing we had the incredible
mesa shawn
in the building great destiny
discussions get all your destiny needs
from the last word it was a fun one some
strong warlock talk
um other than that what else uh chivalry
two been doing that and uh still on my
mass effect grind but
that is all so now that we've gotten
into what the lords have been playing
i want to focus on lord patrick his
video game system history
his tremendous games history experience
industry experience and of course what
led him to
halo one of the most iconic franchises
in gaming history as well
as the hottest multiplayer reveal that
has taken the internet by storm
but first lord patrick let's start from
the very beginning what was some of the
first video game systems you had
and what got you in the game uh let's
see
the very first video game system i had i
believe was the sega game gear
wow first game gear reference as addict
checks out
like when it comes to consoles i don't
know anything about and i never
played it just goes to one i don't even
hear it i just like the face you make
when you don't know
what so so the game get
all right so at that time nintendo was
right i don't need to play by play
already
i can totally google that if i wanted to
figure that out you know what the
history
is crazy um but anyway so
what what made you make that choice was
it the color black lip screen what was
it was it the spell of it
[Music]
so luckily like my my dad was pretty
into
tech stuff and for for him he was just
like he saw the game gameboy in the game
here and he's like oh no the game gear
is way cooler because you have like
color
having that backlit the color like you
know as a machine at the time it was
definitely ahead of its time right yes
absolutely although you
you went through double like batteries
i mean yeah like most of us we played
tethered to the wall
real quickly any any game gear standouts
any specific titles
oh i mean like this was it sonic 2
that was on the game gear right
there's it's been a long time rage
they had all a marquee games that were
there uh
that was the enticing part to it because
if you had a sega console
this sega game get tried to emulate
those games onto the sega
game gear and they did it in a world
fashion and like
the biggest problem with the game gear
and the nintendo uh
you know handheld had the advantage on
it was battery life yeah
the battery life and the color so you
went for gay gear was the first that did
what did you kind of progress to as far
as those other systems you had oh man
we're gonna go
through that so yeah i started as a sega
kid so yeah i got the sega genesis
after that was my first home console um
then switched over to the n64 wow
so yeah okay and look at adding space
easy yeah yeah
yeah it went from n64 but then back to
back to sega to
dreamcast
he wanted something he wanted something
now yeah i love that console yeah so had
the the dream
cast and the gamecube for a while there
all right okay question
i want to bring it right back to the
game uh a dreamcast
all right so we all know on the nintendo
you probably got mario in the beginning
right
yeah like everybody probably the
greatest platformer
and you know for a launch console
question
for the dreamcast being at the dreamcast
library had 22 titles at launch that was
absolutely amazing how many of those
titles did you walk home with on day one
did you get day one or did you get
uh a little bit later good question uh
not quite day one it was a christmas
gift
okay okay it was sonic adventure
uh jet grind and what was the other one
ready to rumble
it wasn't ready for the rumble i'm sorry
kid boxing
all right yeah that that machine was
incredible the first time
another one uh gaming okay sir i'm sorry
you went together
next continues yeah uh and then that's
after
those is when i made the switch to xbox
got
nice old republic is the the game that
pulled me over
yes
one of the best rpgs uh uh smoking on it
on
on xbox all right question again
let's go being that you got to the xbox
now
um what was your standouts on the ogx
box that you got
besides the knights old republicans i
know that probably was like a real high
high water mark for you yeah well yeah i
definitely was original halo
yes so i started with halo 2.
no yeah i started with halo 2 i then
eventually went back to halo 1.
uh i mean during that time it was like
crimson skies
[Music]
man you you're making me like try and go
way deeper
what what did i get during that time
probably nick assault was good yeah uh
yeah so all right all right okay all
right so let's
let's keep going let's keep going and
then obviously went to the xbox 360.
yeah you know gotta love it uh uh
then yeah no playstation love and down
here
so then um i got the ps3 oh so okay
all right let me back you up so the play
play street was your introduction to the
saudi eco
as far as your first owned sony castle
correct
yeah okay did you get a chance to play
at your friend's house or anything like
that
okay okay so yeah yeah i played i played
playstation games i just never had one
uh yeah so ps3 is my introduction got a
metal gear sold for with that question
did you get
the the the form and grill one
worth more than that if you have the one
that can play the playstation
it had back compat as
just missed it but still had the forming
girl with the spiderman logo oh yeah
it was nice no doubt yeah
like i said from there pretty much every
system on or just you know
yeah yeah basically like oh yeah i
forgot
i skipped the wii uh i didn't get i
didn't get the wii u
uh not a lot of people did either not a
lot of people did
handhelds i got all the game boys after
that as well oh okay
okay that gameboy advance was different
right
yeah actually though here's here's a
weird console oh let's go
the sega nomad anyone oh
but listen the the novelty of putting
the genesis cartridge straight
yes oh my god was mind-blowing for his
time i also want to shout out um shout
out to my boy um john lennon from
digital foundry who we've had on the run
before we got to get you back on sir
um he had an amazing uh video like
uh series on the nomad
yeah you gotta check it out let me ask
you a question did you get a chance to
build devastator
did you put the the sonic the tower the
tower tower
oh yes oh yeah i had to
i think that was it everybody's fixation
once they got a nomad how tall can it go
so um i gotta briefly discuss your
journey prior
to 343 and um you know i'm saying from i
i believe lucas arts you got some
history yeah
oh eva got some game stop history which
i'm so surprised you do so just give us
a background just on the lead up
to the greens yeah i mean yeah gamestop
was
one of those things in college it's like
you know
november holiday higher worked there for
a bit uh but then you know i
was applying to internships and luckily
we got an internship at lucasarts which
was
mind-blowing at the time i like that was
a dream come true moment
back then like i was like i got that
letter i'm like
what is happening this is crazy
yeah so i did a summer internship with
them and luckily that turned into a job
which was
wild it was an amazing experience uh we
were making
a really cool game not 13 13.
we're making a another a shooter that
would i think would have
uh appealed to a lot of people in this
room uh
and though obviously we got shut down
yeah um
yeah but uh yeah and then you know i
interviewed a few places including 343
and they're like oh hey we have this
like
role on the campaign team do you want to
come on over i'm like of course
yes so up up until that point you have
played already
all the halos up until that point before
you got
the call then yeah all right okay so
let's get to that let's get to that
i'm saying it to that 343. and um yeah
like also
just real briefly um halo initially when
you got there it was uh
halo 5 the campaign aspect right so uh
can you tell the run briefly like what
you did on halo 5
yeah so i got hired on as a role called
the props coordinator
and what what that means is like when
obviously there's a lot of you know
different parts in halo
and what i handled with the team was
like all of the props that
you know animated you know reacted to
physics it you know
exploded got damage interactables
uh i am so grateful that that was
my first job at 343 because it really
allowed me to like
learn so much about the engine and all
the different parts
uh that i was able to just really dive
in
right absolutely uh yeah and so like
because of that they're like oh we need
someone to like prototype like
some bigger moments in the campaign
like can you can you do that and so like
a prototype uh
a few i prototyped uh the
the guardian run running down the side
of the guardian
okay uh excuse me um
for anybody that's not uh well versed in
the terminology of prototype what does
prototyping
mean yeah so prototyping is basically
getting something in engine that uh
proves an idea
and uh answers questions because there's
a lot there's a lot of prototypes that
obviously like do a prototype it you
know
it works and all that but it answers the
question of like sometimes like yeah
this is
what's right as well okay so not not all
prototypes move forward it's it's really
a very quick thing too
okay and answer a question of like okay
what are we trying to do
like does this like are the goals like
you know met all that type of stuff so
okay so like they're
trying to be there we were trying to
solve like all right what kind of big
moments are we going to have
there's a few there's a few others as
well that obviously
didn't make it right right yeah and so
like
that one and like uh figuring out how to
do like the space elevator
um and so the space because of that
like wit at the time there's a lot more
missions because you know you always go
through cuts right
there are production but they're like
hey you want to take over this space
elevator mission
you know you obviously know what you do
i'm like yeah sure let's do it
so all right nice yeah so so so they've
seen your experience they've seen
exactly how good you were working
and they just started giving you more
work like every other boss does
exactly as you show your talents they
send you more stuff down the pipeline
right
yeah okay all right yeah that's awesome
man would love to hear that kind of
stuff and the progression obviously
being before you know what i'm saying
halo infantry a lot of people didn't
realize that you know
yeah but as as my my boy lord solver
saying we gotta get to the reason why we
are
here yes that amazing
trailer so we gonna get that kicked out
right now
a new day is upon us a new
generation built to fight
together we are unstoppable
are you ready
[Music]
killing spree
hello let's do some damage
return it to base
ordnance drop inbound
the flag is ours
please call us at your earliest
convenience
now show me what you can do
so lord patrick after oh that incredible
halo
infinite goodness that we just saw you
know so i just
actually want to do a brief q and a with
you in reference to the things shown in
the infinite
sandbox trailer the multi uh player
reveal trailer shorter e3
so like as a developer who worked on
guardians obviously like
what do you title five guardians what do
you think stands out the most
between then as far as the feel of the
game and
infinite in your opinion yeah uh
i think you know halo 5 like
you is really like you know you're a
fighter jet in the in the armor right
you know you have
like your thrusters and ground pound
you know is really about where the goal
that we're trying to do with halo
infinite is like you know the armor was
a extension of the player uh
what to do um you know with with
hello infinite you know we were we were
looking at a lot of
you know what what was kind of the
history of halo you know how
how do we modernize the legacy a bit
more as
uh you know uh some people talked about
and
so it was really about uh you know
finding the right
what we felt was the right kind of knobs
the term for like
modernizing halo mm-hmm awesome awesome
hold on one second oh yeah yeah i'm
gonna follow up i just want to say um
you know the other thing is you know
obviously you know with your role as far
as the multi-player system designer and
um
you know i want to know specifically if
you could tell a realm about the pelican
systems
and the the new personal ai
that we seem to sign to us you know i'm
saying that each individual spartan
seems to have in this trailer
because there's going gonna be another
iconic voice besides uh jeff snicer sir
what's going on with this ai and pelican
systems i gotta know that
yeah dave the personal ai we're really
excited about it
it's something that you know the team
has been wanting to do for a while
because we're
all about player expression and like
putting you
as the spartan right so it's it's a
it's really cool there's going to be a
lot of fun
voices that i think everyone's going to
argue what their their favorites are you
know
you you heard erica ishii is uh lumu
um but can't talk too much more
exclusively
i think once uh people will we don't got
samuel jackson voice in there
it wouldn't be fine from a personal
opinion
your king you'll kick your kick sergey
sergeant joshua
you know what's funny too like i i've i
liked how you guys
have you know you picked certain things
in the front in the game and you've
added things
that's like the possibilities are
endless that you can do
like you can literally bring other
voices from
other like microsoft games into it
you can you can you could have marcus
talking from gig
like you can do a lot of stuff with it i
think the whole
infinite title uh is going to uh
transcend
into the game and the thought process
going i think that was like a bullet
point on the on the board
so seeing the multiplayer uh the
infinite possibilities my thought um
my question for you was and i thought
about this
when we knew that you were coming on i
really thought about this all week
um and i thought that infinite uh
spread to the character customizations
what what i'm what i want to know is and
because the ai
that could be yours and yours only like
everybody in your fire team won't have
your same voice ai
right um my question is was
customization
per character making that spartan
your own um like one of the main goals
when you guys was putting together you
know the multiplayer being for the
multiplayer aspect of it
i yeah like there's since i'm uh
focused more on like most systems i
can't talk like a ton
to that but like yeah yeah yeah like as
from what they show
but yeah as like a goal like yeah we
want like
this spartan to like be the ultimate
expression of of the player that's why
we're going so hard into customization
because we want
every player no matter you know who you
are
like the thing that i'm most excited
about that we show is
like all the um uh the
different limb types that you can hear
yeah you can just do the hand you can do
the whole arm
yeah you know like you know we wanted
every player no matter who you are to
like have a reflection of
who you are that's what you i was gonna
say you know what's next now right yeah
you add that that anime factor where you
can just extend the limb and grab
something
we got the grappling hook for that sir
yes
we can we can have both
what what i noticed is and the only
reason why i said it because i was
looking at all the spartans i probably
watched this in half speed
and i've watched i watched this thing
like probably 500 times
and i watched it in half speed but i've
noticed like it was like every spartan
was come almost completely different in
some form of faction
even if they have like decals or
whatever they had and it seemed like it
was like personalized but then when we
got to the samurai looking one
who actually grabbed the sword and cut
them through
i mean that's probably my i'm still
getting goosebumps
that was like the highlight um and
that's why i asked that question yeah
and
i know you weren't like in that area but
um i i thought it was like probably a
bullet point
oh you definitely yeah
when it comes to the halo community
we got some real like i wouldn't say
like
complicated people because i consider
so like how is it working on a game
that's so beloved
that you know the littlest thing you
could do could upset
thousands to hundreds of thousands of
people
because like like being myself like i've
always been like one of those middle
ground people that i can accept change
and then there's you know obviously the
halo fan that you know they don't want a
whole lot of change they want the
pure core like how is it as a team to to
work around that to have that
that mentality it's like we got to do
this right because we have a fan base
that will get us if we do it wrong
yeah i mean it's it's one of those
things where no matter what we do we're
not going to be able to
please everyone right so like the way
that we go about it is you know this
this is a this is a halo game right this
is a
this is a halo ass halo game
but you know so but you know games have
changed a lot over time there's
tons of different things so like we look
at like
what we think will bring it all together
to make
the best halo game possible and you know
one of the ways that we're doing this uh
is like through the academy
you know you know we got we got 20 years
of halo
and you know with free to play we want
to bring new people in right
and like it was a huge thing really
early on
of like how how can we introduce players
into
this world in this game in a much better
way than we've done in the past and
like i i'm really excited about the
academy there's a
lot of awesome stuff in there yeah i'll
talk about it
just to double down on what attic is
saying and solve i'll get you in a
minute i just want to double down to
some great points that uh attic mate
you know obviously in reference to the
community trying to respect the
community but at the same time push it
push it forward because obviously we see
some things initially
in the trailer you know as far as like
it appears correct if i'm wrong like
sprinting while shooting and reloading
you know we've seen um i don't i didn't
see thrust necessarily but maybe thrust
as an equipment
so um you know you also have okay is
that correct what i didn't know i said i
said who knows
who dawg is what you're doing i'll talk
for you
all right and then um
you know the other thing obviously the
grappling hook huge thing as far as
traversal
you know it seemed like it appears to be
earned you can
hijack with the grapple that looks crazy
but one of the things i like from pvp
standpoint is um
you know and i think i believe destiny
starts to do it is that
you know if you have this equipment and
you get killed
it drops for the next person and i think
that adds a whole new layer
you know to the dynamics of using the
equipment making sure you use it because
you want to use that overshoot before
you go on any type of engagement because
if if you go into an engagement you're
like 2v2 and
when you get clapped off and someone
jumps up and grabs it and they use the
overshield
now it's going to be a 1v pretty much a
2v4 because they got
two shields let me ask you a question
real quick about that because i
actually had that when it comes to how
you use weapons
i don't know if you can answer this but
is there like when you use an over
charge or anything like that is there a
certain like
you just don't pop it immediately right
like there is a second
where there's like a delay like okay i
thought so because
like to me it's like i don't want that
scenario where i go up on someone and
someone
just grabs an overshoot and just pops
that [ __ ] immediately
and then it's just like i lose the
engagement because i couldn't get to it
yeah if you look at our at the uh you
know multiplayer overview
the third the third person actually both
shots like you see
like how long it takes to
pop that over shield so there's
definitely some time that is like a
little window
okay all right awesome okay so get in
there i know you want to you have some
stuff you're going to ask
yeah i mean for me just just the idea of
you guys
now making a free-to-play game right how
does
he took my parents how does that
oh yeah like how does that change your
approach to what a halo ass halo game
is because because it it would be it's
the first one right so
you know are we and a couple of
interesting things that i've seen so far
is you guys have sort of been talking
about how you're
you it's your spartan you're going to
have this narrative through line with
your spartan throughout
throughout the story of the the
multiplayer mode so it's like
i look at that and i'm like hmm i look
at fortnite and it's
success and a lot of it comes from the
fact that i you know that
that there's a narrative through line to
that world where it feels
literally alive right yeah you have so
many people engaging with it on a daily
basis
it is a living world and you guys are
sort of the puppeteers there where you
can drop in
drop things in and out you can you know
you can blow the world up
the halo ring like you can blow the
world up are these the types of things
you guys are thinking about
you can't say but but when you
think about how how does this game last
for so long right you want this game to
be a living
infinite quote-unquote infinite thing
yeah is that the type of stuff you guys
look at in terms of
how do we create a narrative around this
multiplayer experience of halo
i mean we look at a lot of different
things right like
we're all playing all types of games all
the time we're paying attention to what
everything's doing
but you know whatever however we do
things in the future like it's it's
going to be
what we think is best for halo right
we're not you know we're a team
that you know gets inspired by things
but we
want to make sure at the end of the day
it's what is an awesome halo experience
no
absolutely absolutely um so one more
thing in terms of um
when you talk about like maintaining
that that idea of the 30 seconds of fun
right and and having these bigger
environments what have you guys done in
terms of the environments to sort of
ensure that those sort of
mini engagements happen and people don't
don't end up by themselves in a big
area uh
our i mean our level designers are
awesome they're like two of our level
designers come from ford's community
uh like we our lead level designer has
been
is amazing has been in the industry for
a long time and a lot of big studios
like
they're they've done a i think an
amazing job
i think you've seen some amazing levels
already from the
the trailer oh yeah some reach stuff too
so
some levels that seem like they have
like it's there's multiple
points of elevation and just a lot of
sneaky places to be yeah there's there's
a lot of night
they've done a great job of how all the
spaces connect with one another to give
different play styles different you know
strengths and weaknesses
so i think people are going to be really
excited when they play
the levels and all right one last one
ready then i'll leave you all alone all
right so i know you can't say
specifically but but our chat wants to
know okay
is there are there possibilities of
collaborations with other i know adam
mentioned it to um
other you know xbox properties that
collaboration
there are possibilities leave it to
someone to ask questions he's literally
saying i can't calm at all
what if if patrick wants to uh to
elaborate on that
oh my gosh that you already kind of
asked that addict so don't don't
tell me i'm infinite no i never came out
and said
hey patrick is there any chance
i just fixed your question
yeah obviously i can't right one way or
the other
like the one the one thing like i'll say
when it comes to questions like this
like for someone from my level it's
always interesting because people are
like
why can't this person not you know
answer like we're a
big team with a bunch of different
people who handle different stuff so
even if i like answered it in a way i
think is genuine
right there's someone else who might
know way more
than i do and i might answer it
incorrectly without even knowing it even
if i think i'm answering it correctly
right
so those are like i think you know this
is more of kind of a
education for viewers too it's just like
yeah like
there are certain things like i know
about with
stuff in our our game with like
different sandbox stuff or campaign and
things like that but like
i don't feel like i'm the the person to
answer those questions because
even my my information might be outdated
you're perfectly fine does this every
time
i do have a question i don't know if you
can answer this because a lot of people
in the chat are asking it
it just is there i i don't think
is there is there a possibility of
assassination showing back up
it's been like eight super chats on this
one thing yeah they've been crazy with
that
i can't i can't talk
i didn't even like i didn't even know
assassinations was this important
people i love that no i turn that [ __ ]
off because i'm just gonna get myself
killed language sunday sunday
but all right okay so all right i just
want to get this question
i tried that i tried so did i thank you
all right
all right being that i already knew none
of that stuff was gonna work
all right we all know that you know uh
if wherever you engaged in halo and you
you had different uh ideas of what it
meant to you for the multiplayer
for us from us original guys that were
playing on multiple television linked up
in the house everybody quarantined by us
so he's quarantined before it was time
right and we did it
officially every saturday uh my question
is
we had iconic boards right and this is
what i thought
like left after a period of time uh when
i was playing multiplayer on halo
are we going to get back to those when
the name pops up at the bottom like you
see blood gulch
uh are you guys really uh getting
uh iconic boards together and
is that a focal point on trying to not
regurgitate the old boards but make new
boards iconic to get to other people's
favorites do you have like a favorite
when you play
because i'm i'm pretty sure that y'all
got testers and stuff like that
that you're working on wait what do you
mean by boards actually
oh okay well all right so like you know
on the the battlefield the the
multiplayer battlefield so when both
blood goes let's say all of us is
playing right
and it'll randomize it and we're hanging
high
ah right right right right that will
that's really good and hang them high
get real excited and they know they're
going to get the pistol and they're
going to get the shotgun because
it's tight right and if you got blood
goats you know that all right
you know saab is going to run to his
sniper spot you already know that you
the cover is going to be right so this
one i'm talking about like everybody
will have their favorites in their house
and they will uh
they skills will show on these boards
are you bringing back that favorite
feel for certain boards yeah
i think so right you know right i think
i
our sandbox team i is been really
focused on making sure
that like every weapon and equipment and
grenade has its place
for each player right i think i think
what
people are gonna see with with infinite
is like
you know every time you see a weapon on
a weapon wreck
depending on where you are it's like
okay what choice am i gonna make them
is this is this what i want to pick up
or you know am i gonna
go buy like i think you know in uh
in in the overview trailer there's a
really great shot of like
the the tower on live fire yes and i
think that's gonna
you know some people are gonna love that
spot with you know with their favorite
sniper type weapon other people won't
right
so i think i think we there will
definitely be that feeling
of when people are playing all right so
now what i'm getting is
okay so now that i'm understanding now
now is a persistent world because when i
said boards he's like boards yeah
he said boards
in terms of like your your i'm curious
i'm like
right now with uh because i know
obviously you guys have internal testing
with the pvp
like what to you is like your favorite
go-to
currently right now on your testing oh
that's tough that's really tough because
also like
i it depends on if it's btb or arena
right
okay oh the returning
bts
i it's it's it's probably
you don't want to give away his strategy
to the team
feel free to break the acer it's no bad
friends
live fire i think is a really good map
uh and then behemoth what you saw
that yeah the desert map like they're
both very
very different type maps but they're
both so good
what about like the obviously the
grappling hook is in here
have you seen a lot of um unique plays
that you can make with that equipment
oh yeah it doesn't i i i don't
obviously i've never been good with a
sniper but when i saw
in that trailer someone sniped the the
roof
no they they grapple hooked the roof
and i saw that no scope sniper shot
from halfway across the map i was done
with life
yeah listen you guys got so much
going on you know between the physics
base
and you know throwing the grenade seeing
that you know that
what you call the blade come to you you
know obviously the grapple hook
you know with the traversal and stuff
like that you know
you got so much going on and then to
your point you know
audrey sauce point which is you got the
free to pay model right so you got this
huge
influx now pc also you know what i'm
saying yeah
all this bass and big team battle out of
all these
insane things you guys are adding like
in
your opinion like what are the things
that are
really like that you think players are
not
truly ready or or some of your favorite
things to experience that people are
going to go
absolutely bonkers when they when they
actually play this game
oh man like a straight shot
oh yeah that thanks shot yeah there's
those
fun weapons uh i think
i think like the fact that free to play
is like gonna just
open the floodgates and we talked about
like like
i i can't wait for everyone just to be
playing halo on that day one right
right and just jumping into arena match
and being like oh this is modern halo
like this this is this is modern halo
like
and it's i think when
players start like playing with the
equipment some stuff will be pretty
pretty straightforward and then other
stuff they'll be like okay this is neat
and then they'll
see someone do something with an
equipment that you've never seen before
and they'll be like whoa
what what i could do that you know
what's funny
i i was i was like last week's age when
i found out in the original halos
that you can you can come like with a
power lift you can power lift a bubble
in the air never knew that until last
week like
you know what drove me crazy just seeing
the repulsor and um
them besides the reflection of bullets
that that's insane yes
when we saw that on the trailer live
reaction
we're going crazy right so we got you
want to know something crazy
i didn't know you could even reflect
that plasma pistol shut
that's just how crazy that's how in
depth like some of this equipment is
like
it's just integrated with all our
systems you know what it was man they
got tired you give
give them that smoke deer and those uh
those internal testing
but put it you can reflect that i gotta
get
that is super impressive but another
thing i'm seeing
if you look back if you really break it
down using the repulsor looking down on
the ground
and then boosting up to get higher
elevation on a board
like you guys are changing this sandbox
into these very interesting
cool ways and and to king's point you
know
about player expression customization
you know i'll be honest you know as a as
an old school guy i understand the
importance of
red and blue and i get it right but as a
newer pvp
kind of guy i like having the individual
color and i like having that yes
and you guys broke away and are actually
doing that
including like the stances and could you
like talk to
you about the decision because i know a
lot of the hardcore halo community
like red blue but yeah that's why you
know we like some of that modern stuff
you guys are adding can you talk about
that
a little bit uh like the the decision to
like
do your own spartan colors was really
early on in the project
like the one thing that i've heard is
like oh it's just a cell customizations
right but it's it's not actually like we
just as a team like no we want to be
able to
show off customization period right
obvious obviously with free to play
there's going to be you know paid
cosmetics and things like that but that
wasn't
the driving goal like we
like it was a very holistic goal of like
this is what we want
you know halo infinite multiplayer to be
we want
you to see your spartan and yeah it's it
has not been an easy thing because yeah
red versus blue
obviously like is an iconic part of halo
as well but like i think
i you know we're you know in the the
final days polishing things up i think
people will
be really excited when they are able to
see like like you saw the lineup of
spartans that live shot right yeah
lineup shot and all the guys yeah
beautiful good at it yeah
i think once you start like really
playing with seeing all these friends in
game
and you're just like oh there's there's
keen spartan right there like yeah yeah
i'm gonna shoot him in the face
if i have that over shield you want me
you know it's gonna be like you're
really going to know like who you're
going up
against yeah now that's fine before i
pass that that's what i want
um i know like we talked about a lot of
specific things that we know
specifically you can't always
answer but i guess my question in
reference to these things you know
assassins all the stuff we're asking you
like it are things still
fluid in the sandbox coming down to the
to the wire
as far as decisions is whether they're
going to be added or not sandbox stuff
no i mean we're we're in a phase that's
a polish and bug fixing like
we're finalizing the game you know we're
just bringing all together
you know to really make it as polished
as possible for lunch right
you know at some point you got to be
pencils down it's like don't forget
no matter how much you want to no more
no more feature cream
everyone's like let's just let's just
air out let's cross all our t's down all
our eyes we don't want to add a t
over here too many t's over here like i
just remember like this is
unlike previous halos like you saw a
little bit of it and halo 5 is like this
is just the beginning
right yes you know there's gonna be you
know we're going to start out with
season one
you know as we launch and then there's
going to be more stuff
to see what what i really like that you
guys did
is how you're approaching the season
pass like
because because i'm hoping that you put
this pressure on these other companies
i'm looking at destiny
i don't like the fact that well you know
what's funny you guys showed me
something i needed i didn't know i
needed
like i always had that mentality if i
don't if i don't finish the season press
then i'm just i'm just
i'm just out of luck like i should i
should have finished it but then when
when you guys over there like you guys
paid for it you should have access to it
every time i'm like
you know what 343 you're right where you
at fun
well i i feel i feel this right uh as as
a premium content dude
right and i i want i hope this is a hope
and i know you're not gonna answer this
i'm just putting it out there because i
hope they're watching
and they hope they're listening um i
hope that there's a a part where i could
buy some exclusive gear that nobody else
can have unless they have problems
right nfts you want halo nfts yeah
but i don't want i don't want it to
affect gameplay i just need to be purely
cosmetic and i want you to know
oh he has money
i don't know so just to claim
if halo sold nfts the game would tank in
a month
yeah you have no problem buying
microtransactions but new games off the
table okay
i like to i like to have the cool metal
hat that has the wings on the side
like the flag yeah it doesn't have no it
doesn't affect no gameplay
my five dollars for that sir and i am
premium on that stage i love patrick
is there any hope that uh kids will be
appeased by uh
a premium price for uh
so out of curiosity king what is what is
the ideal
for you to what do you want to buy on
that store i'm curious
to walk around as uh on halo infinite
philadelphia this maximum surveillance
oh
listen to actually have on a roman suit
like running around
over my spartan
no no no no no no in roman gear but you
can say it's the fill package
okay all right all right king's point we
gotta let patrick but the king's point
you know i hear him with his robin
package we got a samurai package
right i go a lot i i would like a ninja
package so
fashion if you could if you could send
this to the higher up i don't i don't
like how that's
a ninja package
i like a exclusive suit but we don't
want to we don't want to get too crazy
with microchip but
to your point fashion the things we'll
talk about with
with cosmetics there's two there's two
things like one
like you know everything paid it's all
it's all cosmetic right no matter like
what you're paying for it's gonna be
cosmetic
we're not changing gameplay you know
we've we talked about that in in the
overall
so i can't buy aim assist no no
and then like the exciting thing about
like
the the samurai armor it's it's an event
armor
right so there's gonna be okay okay it's
gonna be it's gonna be free
uh you're gonna have to play the event
to earn it so
you know our our uh you know
customization
team is really into earning making sure
that players can
still earn a lot of things so okay no
doubt i really respect that too
patrick because like you guys are doing
that season pass thing and like
whatever you get from the season pass
you can't buy and i really like that
because i don't like
the fact that like certain things that
you get in other games
like six months later you know we're
gonna put that in the store we're gonna
put a twenty dollars so then it kind of
like
it devalues all that grinding you did i
respect that part too
but you gotta also respect the player
that i don't respect
i work all the time i don't respect you
coming in
i don't respect you coming to the back
yeah like yo
let's say you have the time to game and
grind right and you you got a chance to
finish the
season pass let's just say this is just
some kind of how many times how many
hours have you put it out
right but don't don't worry about it no
no don't even sit here and act like
you're trying
on an argument all right i don't have
the time
i don't have the time i don't have the
time let's just say there's something in
the store that will always be in the
store that's available to everybody
but i can look it's you know special too
i want to look special too
so so i just want you know i just hope
they're really good you look special
that's all i would love
the cool thing is this is is to addict's
point right
is that you know with these kind of
battle passes and seasonal structures
you know soft could have tested this i
think would appreciate this is usually a
lot of them create
this manufactured fomo right right so
it's like damn if i didn't play the
current season with a samurai suit
right right i'm gonna miss out but what
i i like that it appears that you guys
are doing you confirm
if i'm incorrect correctly on blood
patrick is that you know
if you missed right you still can go
back and play that
seasonal track if you have it to get
that that item as opposed to damn i
missed it it's gone forever
there's no way i can get it is that the
case just
for the confirmation yeah that's correct
and also if
if you're starting like season four like
you come into halo infinite in season
four
like uh you can buy that season one
battle pass
oh yeah so pretty much like
what i like what they're doing in there
it's like look like you can you can have
that
remember like all these like cosmetics
that's in destiny called that's like
like the emote yeah we can't get none of
that yeah
yeah i like about halo is like let's say
that
john my my friend john my big bad john
you know he ain't played he probably
ain't gonna play for a little bit but
when i talk him into playing infinite
he comes in at like season five six and
he's like yo where'd you get that
and i'm like you gotta go buy the older
ones and he has no problem putting in
the time
but you no one else is giving them that
i don't think there's another
i don't think there's another game and i
love that that's that's
that's my whole aspect of it you know
because a lot of times you see somebody
do something that you didn't have access
to
and you can't never get it and you know
it kind of frustrates the player that's
there
but the fact that you guys heard it
understand it and has
addressed it very early on that if you
missed something that you didn't get in
season one
you're able to get it in season two and
go back i mean we'll get it from season
one
if you're in season two and go back and
purchase season one i think that's
phenomenal especially i think game pass
lends to that because what i'm
understanding is
in game pass all all first party games
is going to be there
whenever you jump into that ecosystem
you jump into that ecosystem and you're
going to engage just like the person
that's been there all the time
and you're the new guy just getting
there so you're able to get the the
season pass from
from day one when you start that's
beautiful no absolutely that and that
that again all this is is i love what
they're doing with engagement like you
know just love what you guys are doing
just keeping everybody around and you
know not that fomo stuff
obviously free to play ball to play a
huge platforms huge
cross play cross progression right and
and you know quick technical question
again if you can't answer fine but they
the realm is beating me up if i don't
even ask um
ray tracing ray tracing um and and
fidelity fx i'm assuming fidelity no but
retrace it maybe i i can't i can't say
either way all right
yeah okay cool yeah our tech team is
always working on
different things so for the engine like
even even so now even though we're
finishing like
again start of a journey right so yeah
they're looking at
you know what kind of things we want to
do in the future right
absolutely no doubt so here's another
question 343 as a studio
right and um i got to be honest patrick
you know i'm saying
we we would be capping as the kids say
if we did not be honest
you know as far as you know last e3
right and the reception i know that
wasn't your team specifically your your
multiplayer as far as infinite but you
know obviously it was critical feedback
we saw the memes we saw some negative
you know reception initially so
despite the internet saying that we're
not supposed to like it for the record
the lords watched it and enjoyed the
trailer yeah i loved it
we thought it looked great we thought it
was the spirit of of halo combat evolved
we liked what i saw but what i wanted to
ask you was the feel
and the culture of the studio at that
time
to now you know what i'm saying because
obviously you guys showed this
multiplayer trailer
and everybody's like oh my god like
they're back everybody's back on so
what was the feel in the cultural studio
343 at that time maybe at the quote
unquote lowest
versus now i mean like even though
like it wasn't my team like like you
said like but at the same time we're
still one
one halo right yeah yeah so like it it
was it was unfortunate like
you know there were there are some a few
missteps that you know
you know different blogs have talked
about you know we didn't get
exactly to where we we needed to and
you know the the the best thing that
happened was you know
leadership is like okay we need we need
to take
and more time you know like we aren't
going to rush
this product we're going to make sure
people know the time they need
so like even though it was like a hard
moment like
it was also i think a good moment for
the studio of self-reflection and i
think this year
both with the the campaign stuff and
with our stuff like you
you see like the the results of that
right yes
oh yeah the reception was beautiful it
was like the comeback kid story i mean
everyone's talking halo
again the energy is up i'm loving it and
i want to transition perfectly into the
next question which is because you
mentioned
you know leadership and and kind of that
self-reflection moment right kind of
looking at it even again both teams you
got three for those of you even though
you're multi-player this campaign yes
then you guys are a unit so if one team
feels it
this affects the whole the whole squad
oh yeah so what i want to ask is about
the legend because i call him the legend
joseph staton and
um you know i'm saying obviously i'm a
huge bungee fan so
you know seeing him being brought back
onto the project i want to actually like
his
impact with his experience of being
brought
in and like obviously in the later
stages of the project and like
you know how is it how excited you as
far as working with him and just
with the future of halo infinite now
that he's on board
i mean joseph's great i i love working
with him i think
you know with where he is in in the
project he was able to really
focus everything down to like you know
we we were all you know moving towards a
similar goal but like
you know sometimes it's such a big game
things
waiver a little bit here and there
throughout you know
it's just you know a process just like
anything else and he really came in to
really help unify the studio and
with what those goals are and i yeah i
think you know
with the latest inside infinite with
that little blurry yeah
kind of uh see you know how excited i am
with
with working with him so i think i'm
going to open it up to you guys outside
in kings i do have a couple more but i
don't want to be greedy
i got i got a bunch of i had to get that
we got a couple of member questions too
but um
anybody else got anything before i
believe yeah yeah i had a quick question
what what
what what's your what's your go-to
weapon and and halo 1
what's that go to weapon that's stolen
when stuff goes wrong you like i gotta
go get it
i think right now it's the the commander
rifle actually
oh okay okay yeah it's i think people
are gonna have fun with that weapon once
they uh
get in their hands no doubt no doubt
quick uh
question from from the realm in
reference to
um well multiplayer testing on can we
can we possibly expect some type of
testing prior
i mean it's later this summer like okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah just like make sure
make sure you stand up for halo
insiders right like that halo waypoint
like
it's it's coming i know we want to say
when but we're you know we're getting it
all ready for y'all
we appreciate it yeah i i take all the
time you need man yeah
yes yes yes we want this thing all the
time
another question from the chat um they
want to know
how how are you guys working towards
handling cheating especially now
it's free to play that many more people
coming in
they i for a lot of reasons i can't talk
about specifics
exactly yeah obviously there is there is
things being kept
it's like it's pointless telling us how
they're going to cheat
can you tell us
let's tell let's tell the chat that
there's probably some cheetahs in there
yeah can you tell us specifically
obviously though those types of things
are at the top of mind so right
i know sliders are big obviously the pc
community is is getting involved first
you know halo launching simultaneously i
got a shout out to my master race um
you know usually you know those guys
tend to get a lot of the premium
features the fov sliders and all that
stuff
is it also possible console we're
looking for parody as far
as uh feature set i don't know if it's
parity but i know that you'll see a lot
of things on both platforms
so okay you you'll you'll get different
things on
xbox as well okay hopefully fovs are
hopefully
we love we love f.o
yeah i think that was a huge uh game
changer when it came to certain things
question for our move on addict soft
king no
i'm scrolling through here yeah make
sure we appease the realm
real quick because we know that lord has
times limited but we got to try to get
as much as we could in
nothing that i see okay okay now look
you know so um
at the end of the day like i said it
looks phenomenal you know you guys are
really transforming the space
everybody's excited we're pumped you
know i even saw the uh
the waypoint the uh companion app really
a lot of functionality there so that
yeah i remember taking that thing on the
go and being like an extension of the
game
i can customize and do all this stuff
now you know while i'm doing remote so
uh
you guys working with those teams as
well in conjunction with the multiplayer
as well
the um the waypoint oh yeah okay oh yeah
yeah definitely like
you know we have our live waypoint team
that's working on all the services and
making sure everything's hooked up
together so
something we're all paying attention to
also also awesome now
final question i have and it might be
slightly personal but i have to ask it
i thought it was awesome kind of cool to
mention but um
i personally think two devs who are
engaged to each other working on two of
arguably the greatest
fps franchises of all time
my halo and my destiny is an amazing
story i just think that personally so
how cool is it to have that kind of
relation shout out to lady rachel in the
realm salute salute a little respect
you know like how cool is that and then
number two is like
a rivalry yeah like i just want to
respond i want you to risk i want you to
speak for yourself in response to her
hilarious tweets about you and she said
she says more recently her team would be
about well i think i know
that has heard screaming in the
background
in her team meetings he said lord
patrick has been play testing halo
infinite multiplayer with the
multiplayer team
and he might be a bit excited
then she said also the irony is not lost
to me that she works for a studio that
created halo
while her fiance works in the studio
that is currently making halo
and also she never played halo 4 so i
got to let you speak all these things
sir
yeah uh i i might be known as a person
in the studio and here that i get very
excited
and i express that excitement very well
as we're playing the game and then you
know with this work from home situation
you know
that might bleed okay
that might bleed over yeah
what about that halo
so there's a caveat to that she has
played halo she just hasn't
finished a halo game oh okay okay yeah
she's that's more of what she meant she
has played a halo game she just hasn't
said it i love i love to see
it shot again shout out to her shout out
they did a phenomenal job
you know i love what the narrative is
going this year so but i thought the
tweet was her
bro i had it oh yeah it's it's great i
appreciate you indulging that and i
gotta ask before you head out to the
top's limited um
we gotta ask we asked every person in
the round
yes i need lord patrick's
top five video games or franchises
of all time all the time
okay well i'm glad that you said
franchises because that definitely is
yeah that's a great thing
i mean like halo is definitely down
there how can it
uh i'm going i'm going to put i'm going
to
cop out a little bit and put star wars
as a franchise
i will put you know some key star wars
games for me but like
uh so like rogue squadron like was the
game that made me
want to get into games i even wrote a
letter to nintendo and they responded
i'm like this is what i want to do
uh uh jedi outcasts
uh battlegrounds nigel republic
outcasts yes oh yeah yeah
yeah republic commando games you know
i you know jennifer has been a great
recent star wars game as well so like
there's there's a lot of good star wars
games that are close to my heart
nice uh halo we got star wars games
so here here's here's a little bit of a
curveball a game a game that really
like stuck with me long after
i played it was inside oh let's go
yes oh look play dead salute yeah it was
amazing great atmospheric storytelling
amazing every like to be able to tell a
story without
saying a single word and having all the
gameplay mechanics
in the world like it yeah it's something
that like i think about all
fire are you excited for somerville sir
yeah yeah i am and also
play that next game which is looks like
it's going more sci-fi yeah
much but like i want to see so glad you
mentioned that's three
more two more all right uh i think
i think i'm going to have to actually go
with breath of the wild
welcome back every week these are all my
games
this is my guy right here let's go
yeah like i i you know i've played
other other zelda games and has beaten
them like but
it for whatever reason like older zelda
games like took me a long time to beat
like i
kind of leave and come back to it but
breath of the wild i basically like
played through the whole time like i
couldn't couldn't stop
any amiibo love
master mode and the dlc because i hadn't
played any of that so that's been fun
to play through a different way nice
number one let's see where where do i
want to go with this
uh
one more important to you important
title of franchise impacted you
in terms of impacted me for a couple
different reasons and
outside of like game industry stuff
because this is going to be
you're going to be like what let's go
with the the kingdom hearts franchise
baby
do you approve
you know what it makes up for that
breath of the wild
when that came into game pass that
opened up a whole bunch of stuff yeah
i loved it yeah so so now kingdom heart
gets the cosine because
oh because you got to go on game fast
dude
game pass open is up to everything oh
it's such a flawed
weird franchise but yeah i love it
it's it's a weird franchise but it's
like
it's a good weird franchise all right
and give him the last question final
question father question
favorite console of all time any
generation
oh my heart is on this one that's good
he's thinking he's thinking eddie yeah
all generations
you can only have one yeah the one that
i think was
most impactful to me thinking back i
think it's gonna have to be the gamecube
oh i did not see that
squadron there's broke like that launch
was
super smash brothers melee rogue
squadron luigi's mansion
like they're like and then later like
you got resident evil 4
and like you know the eternal darkness
eternal darkness the remake of you know
metal gear yeah and everything like
there's like
i think there's uh there are better
consoles
but like gamecube has a special place in
my heart for where it was
in my gaming history you you know what i
can honestly i always give
gamecube is like it just had like
games that put it on the map like that's
when resident evil 4 was exclusive for a
little bit
yeah that really gave it a lot like wind
waker
put that game on a completely different
level and then
i think what really so that game that
they've never done since because they
know
better now is they did that that legend
of zelda collector's edition out the
gate well i don't think it was out the
gate but
it might have been out the gate i think
you did get it when you got that console
like
but even if it wasn't like
arena time collection the master content
like the amount of value that was in
that was insane
and to this day mike people want
nintendo to do that again but like
because i think
like this year's like the 30th and 35th
anniversary
and people's like oh we're going to get
an anniversary like they're never doing
that again
but i think i think this is the first
gamecube uh we had as best
in my opinion the best mario kart of all
time
what color did you get what what color
console did you get
uh purple because that was all there was
at launch yeah
it was it was gamecube was a great a
solid addition like
as far as nintendo i i think the only
one that beats the gamecube is the
switch that's right
yeah i don't know the n64 was good
we got something to say
343 in the building salute to the entire
team brother salute to yourself we love
what we've seen
y'all doing the lord's work with this
bowtie player right now you got
everybody
excited you you guys in my opinion are
delivered yeah y'all with a shot in the
arm and again salute to the whole team
because the campaign teams came through
they came through i love the new thing
with weapon and cortana
so salute to them for coming through too
and then also i want us to again the
companion app team or all the teams
you guys we know you're getting close to
the finish line holiday and all that
good stuff but
let the fine people know where they can
find you what else you got going on or
patrick
rent of three foot and then you know you
can throw that release date in the chat
yeah you go right over here
[Music]
also like basically that's my my handle
on any any gaming
social platform uh uh yeah you know i'm
working on halo
i i work on on small
like indie horror games on the side so i
was gonna get it that's all i did
didn't you say you had to like cease and
desist someone over that
yeah that was a weird thing to do
recently i never thought i'd have to do
that
um yeah and so we're going to be making
another small one
coming up soon plug that game tell them
what that oh yeah it's called do you
copy
you know it's a you know we did it for a
game jam called the asylum jam
uh it was it was hard like
third or fourth asylum jam and like for
some reason this one just like
exploded like it was it was
wild i've never like there's a there
even though like it's not it's it's not
halo numbers right like
a whole whole other thing but there's
there is a very
big difference when it's like oh this is
just my like small thing i made that
like explodes
compared like this the feeling of this
halo e3 was like amazing and then like
having like this small thing that you
kind of like
poured a lot of like passion into that's
like different
it's just like whoa like people like
this
idea at the end of the day patrick like
you know obviously
there's not a lot of games on the
calibers 343. but you know what else was
it on the caliber of 343
among us and you see the damage it did
like that
i love i love them honestly salute man
so again
to what you're doing tremendous you know
we'd love to have you back in the realm
again
but uh let's get lord again talk to talk
to the lord patrick man before he heads
out man
yeah i definitely appreciate you coming
on man we've been we believe it or not
chad we've actually been working with
this
with this uh individual for a couple
months now to get him on but
yeah i knew how this chat was man we get
anyone from three four three they ain't
gonna even care what we're talking about
they're gonna
what about halo what about halo so he's
like let's wait until something comes
out
so this man
yeah something to talk about every
question would have been i can't talk
about that
nobody it would not have been a fun
interview
[Laughter]
no doubt lord said i'll sell your
salutations to lord uh
patrick no i love i just i'm just so
happy for you guys
on that team after this reveal because i
i know you guys must have been nervous
just you know obviously yeah the
reactions to last year's stuff even
though that wasn't your team but
you're always nervous because i know you
know what you have but you just never
know how people are going to react
so i'm so happy that that everybody is
so
on board and people that that haven't
been on the halo sort of bandwagon
people that play other
you know big multiplayer games are
excited for halo as well
i just i can't wait for it to come out
and halo like
we've talked on this podcast about how
do you bring halo back
and make it what it once was and i think
you
you guys are on that track i think halo
is going to hit
big in a way that we haven't seen in a
long time and i'm just so happy for you
guys
yeah i i think halo about to do that
one-two punch this this
i told you about that once i told you
about that what's funny is
is you can ask like we're very honest
and you know we
we was definitely like man i i hope they
could do it
but you know after we saw that trailer
was like man
343 came with them and then not only did
they come with it
they they they got that spirit bomb man
and they
thought they hit them with them we're
actually calling y'all to come back kids
if you guys can pull this off and get it
to the finish line but i want to get
lord king
to get his salutations off you know what
i'm saying even on the front lines he's
been on the front line yeah
okay let's go i've i've been capping
for you guys i'm gonna have to you know
create i was blindsided with that
correctness
um i i woke up in the morning because i
went to bed elated i didn't care
what anybody said i woke up in the
morning with that crap and i i was truly
upset
like i was working at three four three
um
but um to see the complete 180
uh from the community that will like you
know it's amazing
from the single players showing
and the multiplayer just hit so hard and
hit
all the bullet points so for you guys to
come back the next day to give a deeper
dive
into what y'all were doing and what was
going on
um i thought that was the perfect blend
you gave him a snippet and then you came
right back in while by while the water
was hot
it hit right back at it and gave him a
little bit more
uh to what's going on and i'm hearing
all the stuff melding together
and you guys listening to the community
and bringing us to i am
so happy for you guys i can't wait for
that beta to go out in the summertime
for
you guys to actually get a feel of
what's going on who's doing what and
what actually works and stuff
like that and then you know the stress
test is of course
uh because we know what's going on with
the service we'll be talking about that
later shout out to azure
yes but um to launch in this holiday
season i know you can't wait
and i'm just so happy for you guys and i
so appreciate your time coming on
and thanks for throwing those curve
balls and yeah game cube was definitely
future first game key reference yeah
salute brother all right
and again again super proud you you know
i i was
i got really excited when i saw you on
the the second reveal of the the
in-depth showcase i was like oh that's
my video this is it
what's funny is is i i was half asleep
because i woke up that morning because
like i made video to like two in the
morning i went to work
and then i get up at like 11 or 12 and
the video has been live for forever
and i i i overslept so i'm sitting there
hey i'm watching it on my computer
and the patrick just shows up i pause it
and take a picture of it and send it to
me like this
absolutely it's so good to see you up
there with the entire team
everybody's excited every you know the
legends that all y'all up there
talking that halo tongue beautiful
salute brother enjoy your day thank you
for your time
the legendary patrick ran 343 studios
multiplayer system designer get ready
y'all this four's looking good man we
pulling for you guys to hit the finish
line
so yeah thanks for having me on everyone
it was great talking with dolly yeah
so if you want to get the uh the super
chat sir yes let's hit these likes we
have us
over 700 people uh in the chat please
hit the like share it out
uh drop some gems tell them to watch it
from the beginning yeah
man took time out his day to hang with
us yeah make sure you guys get a sense
of love
thanks love that yeah definitely
appreciate it yeah
we got but yeah ready yeah ready we got
black ronin three five seven five dollar
super chat can we expect to see halo
slash doom slash wolfenstein slash prey
armor or weapons crossover at some point
we asked that question
uh tba i guess then we have gerald mack
two dollar super chat
iop absolute superstars thank you sir
you as well
then we have iron mike five dollar super
chat shout out to the sega nomad it was
nintendo it was the nintendo switch of
the 90s
basically that's what it was then we got
squirrely dan 82
10 super chat sorry i'm late gonna start
to watch from the beginning i have
finally arrived at the east coast can't
wait to get into this podcast with the
greatest podcast in gaming bar
none yeah shout out to the squirrel i've
seen your message on it i just been
really knee deep in work lately then we
got bret bingham 5
super chat question for patrick but we
see more historically themed helmets
like biking or crusader helmets
i think there's a there's a great chance
you will i think you're gonna get that
armor
and and i hope they do you know like you
said you know i'll be able to purchase a
little bit something
i mean to me if this becomes big like
big like that like we could expect
are we going to see we see that concerts
in halo like that
so i think so i just saw some stuff in
fortnite that i don't even like fortnite
but they doing this invasion thing right
now
they thought they would have got me with
the marvel thing i know they got cog
with that marble
oh yeah yeah showed up but um they
didn't get me with that but this
invasion stuff looked really bonkers and
i was like what the hell are they doing
it's crazy what they do with that game
yeah uh black ronin in five dollars we
chat
halo ass halo game i need this plastic
around all the commercials and tweets
that go out now
oh yeah that was a classic galaxy i was
thinking no no
we can't keep that though yeah
big cloud gaming five dollars super chat
smash that like button salute to the
lords of the realm no doubt thank you
sir
man i saw those questions of that chat
man you guys really like
let me just let you guys get them please
guys please
we gotta give y'all smoke today you you
guys get excited when we have developers
on but the here it is
this the realm of the realistic value is
we can't just ask
like obviously we asked a couple
questions because i felt like
it wasn't too too out of the room that
maybe they could have answered like the
assassination thing
i didn't know if you could talk about
that i feel like that's something that
he might be able to confirm or not
but like man i saw people like ask is
343 making a new ip
no
you know i don't give a rat's ass there
you go
okay that's how you handle me just leave
me alone
um shout out to gerald back five dollars
the lord sovereign aka the most thought
provoking super professional thank you
let me let me address someone real quick
i don't know eternal umbra note to self
don't sit in super chats asking any
guests everything ever ever again in the
future
we literally made a disclaimer before we
start the interview
that at this point we're going to cut
off super chat so we can focus
on it that's what that is so the super
chat's during
while the guest is here we have to
respect the time it's very limited so
it's no disrespect to you we have to
read that after
so please don't take it personally we
only had them for a certain we
only have them for certain times we try
to we try to get the most information
for
everyone that's involved and you know
you watching is fantastic you can send a
super chat we're going to read it we're
going to still read your super chat we
just have to value the time
because interrupting the course of the
interview with super chats will never
get the interface and if you
do send something through we're seeing
the super chat
right if it's something that we find
that oh that we didn't think about or
somebody here
says you know what that is in
conjunction with my question
bless you addict um we will definitely
ask that question
but read it to anything specific
specifically
that that can't happen or something like
solving addict was saying where we know
they are not going to be able to answer
yeah because beforehand we are told
not that we're asked what are we going
to ask yeah
so you see what i'm saying so we have to
fall in those parameters yeah we have to
be
we have to be uh ridiculously
professional guys yeah um you know
a a lot of people would ask uh
ridiculous questions like uh
can you what ips you're working on in
the dark
right like excuse me you know damn well
you can't answer that
so so we won't happen exactly continue
so i just had to address that
so we have another one from eternal
umbra but this is what we're talking
about right here yo
morning lords patrick what's the chances
of you guys giving us themed armor for
other franchises gears
see you you asked yeah we did ask them
when you when you ask about something
like
metroid that's that's a whole nother
thing exactly you can yeah
you talk about an internal studio like a
that gears up okay
but he did what happened maybe you might
have doomed stuff walking up you never
know
you shot your shot with those kids i'll
give you credits
i really want um because i've seen the
level of customization per people
right now also there's other people that
don't grind the whole season
they can't do it like get 50 head shots
here
and you're coming from work but you see
attic wearing these great clothes
i want to participate as well um i don't
want to flash some cash
so i want to buy some stuff so it
doesn't affect gameplay please
allow that to grow and i think in that
ecosystem it'll be available
i tell you guys this if you look at
every other really successful
uh free-to-play game the way they evolve
the world
is what keeps people engaged so if you
think about what other games have done
halos they're not dumb they obviously
they realize
he said it we look at what other people
are doing and what makes sense
right so taking that you know that they
they're gonna do
things to keep you engaged in that world
and to keep it fresh you know that
so that could be any number of different
things so regardless of what you want
out of it
i think there's reason to be excited
because you're always going to get
something different i think from no
doubt
continues then we got blue no we have
lunar adrian two dollars super chat and
we did ask
ask about how the cheating will be
handled so thank you sir yes yes
then we got b lou five dollar super chat
well well fighting games aka street
fighter soul caliber etcetera you can
definitely buy
every season pass also war no machenko
and y'all the best gaming podcast out
keep killing it thank you so much salute
thank you brother
then we got lord with the five dollar
super chat salute to the panel
great guest lords halo let's go cog
everyone has a price what what what did
he say about lomacheco
again 25 super chat thank you my brother
hit that like button everyone thank you
so much
then let's put the crest in the chat for
titan 2793
in the realm lord bronze put the crush
in the chat in the chat
welcome your brother yes sir then we got
natra brown
10 super chat great show as always
gentlemen great listen while trucking
down the road
and we got clutch man 5 super chat i can
smell it now the familiar stench of
click bait titles from
dying youtube channels ah how sweet it
is
wow wow there's some smoke there okay
let me roll back a little we got raiden
blade
50 pound super chat thank you so much my
brother
hey just got on have you guys spoken
about kim swift and kojima
i can't remember which one of the lord
said this cog
king kojima needs someone to keep him in
check like the old saying behind him
every successful man said it stands a
strong woman
um i think we've all said that
yeah then we got lamar
ham solo 05
absolutely solo
it's like it's the same cadence as
saying rasco
how are you gaming 60 xbox 25 on pc 10
on ps5
5 on switch everybody i guess people put
your percentages in the chat
i don't even know how to break that down
okay i can tell you how much i gained on
my playstation five
zero percent god bless you sitting there
catching
yes you asked for that one yeah shot
that we got drawn tj 10 super chat hi
lords you think in the halo infinite
campaign there will be a crossover
between destiny
comes to halo as a mission and same
thing for doom guy
he has a hell portal um i mean
you know anything is possible like i
said
i'll tell you this i guess if halo
multiplayer gets
super super super popular no you never
know
no you never know never seen that unless
unless they get purchased i could you
could see doom first
oh you
we don't know that bungie's in pocket
for real pocket
yeah i mean i didn't think that i wanted
to i wanted to ask the question to him
like uh you know because he had the
multiplayer with her and
his and she had some multiplayer who do
they have internal fights about who
[Laughter]
kind of funny because you know right now
established right but his is getting
ready you know the excitement
that would be a crazy nice house he gave
the impression that he smokes in halo
like yeah
yeah i know he did that's why i was
asking does he have like a favorite boy
and you guys
roasted me because i said boy down with
you mad
king it's a map it's a damn board that
i'm going to all right so
but when we used to get the hang of hot
i know what i did to mr hop
so you know i let him pick his own
poison he went there and got smoked so i
know what i'm talking about yeah
man we got one more we got bee lou
two dollar super chats like correction
no maschenko no moss
check it out wow yeah i know yeah yeah
duran references he's fighting bombs
caught up there sir yeah sure we are
caught thank you chad we really
appreciate it thank y'all for respecting
the situation and anybody that listened
to the combat talk earlier
yesterday yes respect you already know
so let's get to the poll
get these joints off the cop final
topics off last week's poll results are
in and the people have spoken to the
question
if your favorite gaming franchise on
your preferred platform then becomes
permanently exclusive on another
platform
which action do you take the winner at
64 percent of the vote
where gamers go where the games are
if your favorite game is uh you're
playing on the platform it resides group
it's coming in at second place at 24
percent of
was the messy laws keep acting like
y'all don't care it's all fun and games
until it's your favorite game that
becomes exciting
last place with only 10 set of the vote
was i'm not picking up a completely
different platform
just to play my favorite game that's a
broke gamer
that's the tcl guys
clearly you have something to say about
this how do you feel about this sir
i don't care if they brought bethesda i
don't i am going to gain hand starved
myself
and you will die you
will die you'll die and let
them die as i will partake listen let me
tell you something
i don't care who buys what all fear
loving war
i really don't care same energy on this
side same on energy on that side
i have a playstation upstairs and
whenever i choose to engage with it if
they have something compelling for me
then i'm going to engage with it but at
no point in time and
me being a gamer that'll lock myself off
because i have brand
loyalty oh it's me you're crazy
we got a new one coming at the end of
the show let's get to these topics let's
fly through these these should be quick
hitters so everyone should be happy
today so uh lord sub
and lord king combo deal seems like uh
what's going on with y'all and uh solve
baby what
queen sarah's just talking about windows
what's going on
the queen's talking can't kick it off
okay um so
everybody knows that window 11 is uh
hitting right now
and what i noticed is uh microsoft
has taken a different stance on xbox
itself
uh being that it looks like uh windows
11 is
adopting a more xbox central
everything it's looking like xbox it's
uh
integrating uh looking like the
dashboard
looking like microsoft is really taking
xbox game pass and all these other
services
more integratedly into it and that's i
think that's their flagship now i don't
know
and i'm not going to get into what's the
technical uh problems that's going on
right now we all know when you launch
a update a user interface update a whole
a software update to your
your system there's going to be problems
not talking about that what i'm talking
about the changing now of microsoft's
philosophy
that xbox seems to be the brand
opposed to microsoft windows
yeah let's see let's get started with
yourself i think king hits it right on
that when you look
at this granular level of integration
with xbox into windows 11 which is
windows 11 is the most ubiquitous piece
of software
right it's everywhere
continue it is the fact that
xbox is such at the forefront of their
messaging for that
it just goes to show you the level like
if you didn't believe the level of
integration and and how xbox has
elevated itself
within microsoft this is the key
to if you seeing this is letting you
know where xbox stands
in the scheme of things um
we talked about 2017 and the
conversation the
famous conversation with phil and satya
and how that saved xbox
and how he convinced satya that xbox was
core
and integral to what window to to what
microsoft was doing in the future
and he needed to do that in order to
keep xbox alive
and to see this at this level
is is is so heartening and to know
you know a lot of people have had issues
with how windows
does everything in the gaming space in
the past windows 10
in terms of having this this weird store
that doesn't work well it's slow it's
laggy it doesn't compare
i think this is showing you that they
they're trying to build something that
is finally finally
gonna kind of try to test the might of
steam
in the long term and again and then
attaching it
at such a ground level to windows 11
and giving windows 11 like the windows
10 out as a free
as a free upgrade um
it is windows has if we talked about
game pass being the trojan horse
that brings x by the xbox ecosystem into
people's homes
then windows 11 is the chosen host
that's going to bring
x it's going to bring all of xbox into
when they when they talk about billions
and who they want to reach
in gaming this is showing you how their
what their real plan is right because at
the end of the day
when you speak of xbox on its own as
just a gaming thing
that still sort of eliminates certain
people from even engaging with it
because it's just
people just don't engage with it if it's
just an xbox thing even if it is an app
somewhere
they just won't integrated at a ground
level on the thing that they use
every single day and they can't escape
it
yes let me ask you this song because
you're making some fantastic points and
you know in the past can we can we say
like
maybe we could admit that like we felt
like xbox was
the side project that you know it was it
was the hernia it was the hernia on the
side of my heart you know
right like in the early days let's just
be honest it was one of those things
that we felt like
okay we're going to throw our hat it's
being microsoft right we're throwing our
hat
in the ring right because this looks
like a lucrative thing that we could get
involved with
but really windows all right
that's the mean thing and we'll see what
happens there and then slowly over the
years you know 360 and all that stuff
and it
it does start to get traction starts to
be profitable you know whatever
and like to your point saw cause you
make a fantastic play like do you think
now
and i gotta i gotta hit king with his
dominance talk and i said because you
know
sam phil has has elevated xbox his
position
he's presented it's phil dominus maximus
or really
sorry thank you i'm just saying
i'm just trying to figure out like that
we just talked about phil diamond as
maximus are really a
yes correct yes
you know once you know he's got it to
the table and and sacha and now
do you think to your point like you said
something like this was i know game
class was one of the plays right
because you got to sell it to the brass
okay xbox is profitable
because of this right right we could
make money with this
but now with with this window do you
think like this is the ultimate play
that this is this is
true i think at least yeah i think when
when we talk about that conversation
they will never know what happened there
i think this was always the conversation
like okay
let me show you how what i want to do
with xbox
at your most at the level where where
where microsoft reaches everyone is is
going to affect
this right and i think this was always a
conversation we just didn't think about
it because
you know they hadn't talked about
windows my assumption honestly before i
heard windows 11
yeah it was that we never get another
numbered windows again
and it would just be iterating on 10 and
that's it
so the fact that all of this is in the
pipeline
and and it's inch like i said it's
integrated at a ground level to such an
extent
that yeah this to me this was the actual
conversation and this is this and this
is where satya was like
man all right cool let's go for it how
much money do you need so
out of curiosity you guys are talking
about conversation conversation this
conversation that
what is this conversation because i
wasn't here the conversation that phil
had with satya when he had to
prove we had to prove to satya that the
xbox brand
you know in 2017 when it wasn't doing
too hot
and that the xbox brand was going to be
core to what microsoft wants to do
it's probably easier to win an election
than it is to win that or
that conversation yeah like you got it
like he must have been like
a like award worth smith genius oh yeah
and you know you know phyllis phil is
full of
full is great at using the words and but
the thing about it is that he had to
convince the man
that okay everything that we've been
doing to this point throw that out the
window
we he had to sell him on something brand
new yeah
that hadn't been done in the game space
before and he knew it was going to be a
lot of money
that needed to be spent to get it done
right good point
could have easily said no imagine get
out of here he must have been so
good because they buying companies for
7.5 billion dollars
but how how how wonderful is the genius
and the planning behind this individual
right because to get not just only to
get
the brides to be like okay cool uh we're
gonna green light that game pass thing
that you're doing it
to get the brass to be like from a
ground
level in our main
business we're going to make sure that
it's integrated to a point that is so
intuitive
that when they pick up their phones and
if they're
using that app the game pass app or or
anything that there is no change
from when they interact with us now it's
no longer
are you it's an us now right you
understand
like because when you turn your pc on
and you load up windows 11
is it your xbox dashboard or is it your
pc dashboard right
or are they one in the same it turned
into a synergy
of minding and it's no longer like like
you said a hernia
i'm just thinking about a painful
situation
but it's no longer a hernia on the side
it's actually mind body and soul
heartbeat is one they're moving as one
unit yeah to get to those billions and
is this the strategy into that
billionaire
maybe not her near maybe appendix the
appendix you have it there but you don't
need it
i just want to jump in too because um
also i was thinking about like shout out
to one bad buddy
actually says what i'm what i'm about to
say which is remember
part of these steps to get here right so
right
you know the xbox community had to go to
quote unquote
i would consider fanboy growing pains
right right so it was like
remember games will come in the first
part they're going to be on pc
game pass and then we got game pass pc
and all this other stuff so pc was
brought up to the mix and and i remember
there was resistance in the beginning
remember
people were like yo you know saying i
don't feel whatever whatever
it's interesting to see what this
long-term vision done comes out to
because now
you're having these cool features you're
having the pc community now
integrated in it you're seeing you know
windows 11
or pc integration and auto auto hdr
coming all these
features on the console side you know
whether it be the api stuff the direct
storage stuff
you know now going to be able to
maximize their ssd drives to what you
know series x and get those doing
what they're doing exactly so it's like
that's actually helping
pc gaming and performance in the city i
want to shout out slo-mo he's
he's that shout out to bravi he's in
there pc bastards you don't say because
now
the pc community is also benefiting and
then we already established that synergy
you should i'm saying between the
ecosystem so it's not going to be
as much as a blow as the other company
for example like you know
you can see they're trying to you know
pc releases not saying they're trying to
have that same level of synergy
but i feel like what the xbox brand did
well and what phil did well was
definitely brace that
the brace the base to say look this is
happening and now
it feels like synergetic you got it it's
natural like you don't you
it's natural you accept it and it's and
it's you know
because they did it right they were they
were forward-facing about it they didn't
transparency they were super transparent
about it and another thing when you
speak about synergy
is the fact that they realize that and
they've been kind of quote-unquote you
know
maybe short-changing on the pc side on
game pass
and they're working towards getting
parity there where
you're gonna have a lot more releases
that are super pc centric for that base
to get people to move because again
one of the things that that's difficult
on the pc side is that
steam is king yes steam is king and
you're gonna have those that just don't
you know obviously we talked about how
the the all the all the
the fur around uh the epic game store
has sort of died down and you just it's
just another it's
it's another sort of freaking launcher
so
i do have something because i got to go
here in about ten people
that's yeah okay i do got something that
me and king need to talk about oh so
king
how do you feel that it's rumored that
ghost shashim is having a standalone
expansion now
a standalone expansion yeah
actually diller kind of leaked it you
guys didn't see
it's supposed to be on like like the
kind of like level that like miles is
and the level that like lost legacy was
okay
so now it looks like yeah so ghost is
doing it on top of the other spoon
you're doing it
like part of me feels like this is kind
of
lost legacy i felt like opened up the
avenue with them where they're like
let's it's kind of weird to have so many
expansions for like not necessarily like
expansions like standalone expansions
for all of their games now like but i
think you know what that is i think
that's
i think because let me just real quick
like it started
it could have started before to my
knowledge it started with the last
of us where they they did that little
last of us
yeah and then it looks like they did
with uncharted uh the uncharted
franchise uh then they did it with uh
because
people in the chat can be mad all they
want they did with spider-man with mas
morales
and now it's looking like they do it
with ghost to sushima
so it it it's kind of interesting
the direction that like they're making
like a little standalone expansion for
all of their games
oh this is what my daughter does when
she makes a dress
right she makes the main dress okay you
know the main dress is beautiful
but all the little pieces that she had
cut off of the mane to make the main
dress is still on the floor
and she did pay for this material so
she's not just going to gather up that
material and throw it in the garbage
no it's still valuable material she's
going to she's going to craft a little
dog suit
for my dog out of that stuff and she's
going to use all the scraps that she can
because she's going to get the most out
of a dollar sony
is just like my daughter and she's being
they're being very prudent with their
dollar
what they're doing is they already built
this engine they already built this
world they already built
everything and then they probably go and
refined it and retool
it and let's do a little small something
let's put a little studio on this and do
a little small something
what these scraps that we have left over
from this main game that we already
gouged them with
and let's make this out to be something
else and i don't see nothing wrong with
it um
but again that's something i won't
partake in because
i feel that if it's not priced right
i think you're you're doing yourself a
disservice what do you think the price
is gonna be
it should be that 15 is 39.95 going to
be 15.
yeah this is what i'm saying but being
out there at the 70 dollar range now you
have to scale your
money back to like he said 49.95
i don't remember was miles 70 at launch
i don't know i think
it was 50. this is why but had their
games never made that 10
jump right miles would have been 40
right actually i understand y'all
throwing me off i thought addict was
going to mention with ghosts
the rumor of you know coming a pc oh no
i know
we know that we're going to talk about
that
we can't be talking about that that is
definitely going to be
that that has happened
so what was it the the only on
playstation logo was removed from yeah
they took that off
right so they they said they said that
they they were doing a complete
sort of rebranding right and they all
the ones i'm gonna have that
was stuffed but but it gives yeah it
gives them that leeway
so they don't you know they don't have
to keep answering that question
well this is what happened with
spiderman right they did the logo
this ain't nothing new they listen if
y'all like seeing what they're doing
you're foolish
once we made all the money from you and
it's not
all of you there's only like two percent
of you that's actually you know what's
probably happening
no peace you probably have the ghost of
yoshima and the standalone
they're gonna bundle those together to
try to charge seventy dollars
and that that bundled service is going
to be on pc as well that makes sense
so part of me is like if they're putting
because obviously we don't know if they
do that
okay
they don't care about listen they're
gonna get the pc dollar
they gonna get your dollars and it's
gonna be in an epic store
so y'all gonna be mad that is it i can
see it all already
so what with the um it's been a lot of
stuff going on
playstation there was that a uh that was
that
oh my gosh apparently apparently um
demon souls call it the the the
playstation 5 directory or something
like that to store
the ps4 directory
yeah they're saying that it could just
be like a port up
of of the playstation 3 version for ps4
do we think that like i mean if you if
if you look at demon souls
besides the layer of for a yes or no
question
yeah it could come even easily come to
ps4
what about you cognito do you think you
can come to the playstation 4.
i wouldn't be surprised wow i told you
october i wouldn't be surprised
you know it seems a lot of the
cross-generational stuff
was you know has been coming out but see
i i wouldn't know i would normally say
no
but then that godfall just be looking at
me down the face
it's like like they have too many games
that they
they they came out there as far as their
marketing to sell the ps5
that they kind of low-key said this
isn't possible on last gen hardware
now all of those games are coming but
like this is the thing is too we also
have to factor in the fact that you know
there is i don't
turn this into a playstation discussion
but um the ps5
shortages right the the fact that
consoles are still
you know they're selling out but they're
not in abundance to where everyone
really has one
so are you really going to be profitable
by making it next gen only in these type
of
conditions right so that's another
factor that may get them to shift
quicker and say hey we still gotta rock
this cross-generational flow
but the thing is i i think and shout out
to colin moriarty because he's always
saying this and it's true
when you look at the amount of
playstation it's like the paradigm has
shifted because the truth of the matter
is that they're
more playstation fives out in the wild
now than at the same time this
this this time in the ps4 generation
right so there
are more consoles out there so you can't
make the the argument doesn't hold water
necessarily if you do it if you compare
it one to one
right so it's just the fact that it's
it's smart
business it's smart business gym dancers
yeah i mean i told you before he's a
money man
he's the numbers dude and you don't you
guys can sit there and say what you want
i don't care he don't care
what you want you could put all these
petitions up to get him out of there
he's not going nowhere every everything
they're doing is smart business the
owners
the mistake that they made was not being
forthcoming about it right and just
having to roll back everything to say
and oh and all he's doing he's not going
back on anything he says
his answer to everything is i don't see
why people are mad at this
not acknowledging the fact that he said
something he says totally contrary
before that would he but the problem is
uh
the thing is though king it's he didn't
come out and just not state nothing
he came out and set expectations that
wasn't realistic right
like yeah it would be different
if he'd ever stated anything if he just
if he just pr his way out of every paper
box he's ever been in
when he has it like he made definitive
statements
and he and he put his flag in the ground
when he knew
that flag was 20 feet back well who but
who was that for
that was that was for the initial buyers
right
mm-hmm all right so they already cop
everybody got you got
all right so um now that you got you can
switch this up
all right yeah but you can't tell your
whole base we only believe in
generations
so what what what photo
he already knew where to go though
listen i understand what you're saying
from a bottom line
he don't care because this is a big guy
i get what you're saying
on a cutthroat corporate business level
but with actual communication and
transparency
you who thought that they were getting a
console
for these types of experiences only to
find out
that it is actually being shared
experience with
and you know hold up let me tell you
something real quick king and i'll give
it to you
the the craziest thing about this is
that people a lot of people are trying
to compare this to like phil spencer uh
quotes he's done in class right and like
the funny thing is like
every time people as has has said
postmates or lied about something or
he he misspoke about something it's
always out of context
like yeah like like francis is the
actual fact
for instance when it came to oh you know
we don't consider
uh playstation a he was talking about
cloud services he wasn't even talking
about the game they
aren't they they aren't a competitor
it's these dudes that think that
but back to what jim does right jim does
not care
i mean i want to talk about that and i
don't i don't i don't i don't care what
anybody it's
we believe in generations yes so what
this is
for you guys to sit there to believe
that that stuff
can't be is it ssd the ssd it's you guys
is running around here
thinking that you are superior and he's
just showing you
stop it but you you want to continue
with this argument
and every game is going to be shot down
i hear it now with the ratchet account
it can only be done in playstation 5
but soon you will be
i don't like being lied to do you
because like the way you're talking
like you're cool with it it's like they
just got eating not being lied to that's
the whole thing
they see you could tell when somebody's
lying to you because you and then
it takes one time to get lied to right
then you look at it when you if you
don't do the quiet night at that dude
two times shame on me i know that's
right that's on you all right so now
this is the third fourth fifth sixth
seventh time he don't lie
and you're gonna sit there surprisingly
i have to
i'm gonna i'm gonna have to look at you
sideways from now on right so i've been
looking at him sideways
he ain't doing nothing that i didn't
expect he didn't do anything that i
didn't think was gonna happen
but okay to the point of this
when are y'all gonna start with it can
only be done here
we can when are we gonna stop this when
are we gonna stop
running with that narrative the power of
this and then it's being shown on the
old console right
you're already in pocket so stop you we
got you and
look at everything that you see
everything that's on that console right
now
when you say it can only be done here
you yeah for you because you got it if
you don't got a playstation 4 you damn
right it can only be done here
but if for that playstation 4 dude
it can be done over here but
it it does speak to how game pass has
changed the conversation so much where
in the past you could get you can get
away with
those those fibs right for a lot longer
and at the end of the day your base
probably won't care
now like it it it caught up to them
almost immediately
like immediately right a lot of times
before the games came out
they had to come out and say this is
coming out for the previous council as
well like
so it just to me
it's just heartache that like you said i
don't think jim ryan cares about
whatever heartache right so let's let
somebody let somebody else deal with the
backlash you know
of the community or whatever the case
may be um
but it just doesn't it my message to
anybody who still holds out hoping shout
out to
kmega and the crew over at grg we're
talking about this on friday i was on
the podcast on friday
and the reality is they're doing
everything that microsoft is doing it's
just that
they're late to the party they're very
late to the party
they did they did not read the tea
leaves correctly right
and at the end of the day certain things
that they should be
sort of ahead of the curve on or out at
least on the curve
they're behind the curve right then you
couple that with the fact that they just
don't have microsoft money
to do what microsoft is doing to the
extent that microsoft is doing
and it's going to be very difficult
for them to catch up to microsoft in
that respect
i want to jump in one point because
there is a part of what king is saying
that i do agree with which is
you know fan bases i think they
are cognizant that the fa their fan base
is very prideful with exclusives their
fan base is very prideful with their
tech and like king was saying as far as
the oh it can only be done you know the
ssd talk we heard that you know at
nauseam and stuff like that right
so i i i do think there is a healthy
fear of upsetting this loyal base who
wants to be treated special who wants to
feel
like yo i made this decision in the
ecosystem and
and this is why i'm here and i think
that's why you get a lot of the
hesitance
in in the messaging and just to contrast
it back on point where we were talking
about
windows 11 in xbox stuff like
xbox got and microsoft got land bastard
you know
for for saying halo infinite i mean was
it cross-generational type remember
those days right
you know it was it was a narrative that
they didn't have to
put out right you know this is something
they could have kept
internally they didn't have to say this
can be played on a base xbox one or
whatever right
and then then this the talk starts to
happen it starts to snowball
oh it's like a form or a fear of missing
out on
quote-unquote graphical performance that
i'm not supposed to be missing but then
you see these games and even to the
playstation base
right they start to see ratchet cake
which looks phenomenal and all that
which is you know i mean and you start
to see um i mean harassing that ratchet
horizon forbidden west that looks
phenomenal right and if you didn't tell
anybody
it's a cross-generational game you still
look you still you're still fine right
right so it's just one of those things
where i think again with transparency
and the vision of microsoft
this kind of saved them in the loan they
took in the long term
yeah xbox fan base was not feeling
a lot of this stuff they wasn't feeling
pc games but is this shattering the
narrative and the fear of
um the older consoles holding back these
consoles now
i think for a lot of people it doesn't
you said no but i'm just saying you said
you saw for a horizon forbidden west
right and you saw how graphically it
looked it looked really nice
yeah yeah it looked really nice so but
knowing this i know where you're going
knowing this knowing that it's a
cross-gen title
and you saw the playstation 5 version
and
we know that it's not going to be too
far off on that playstation 4 pro
and the playstation base right is that
shattering
what that misconception is that video
games aren't on a slider
right and it's going to be held back no
with all the crowds
look all i'm going to say is this i
think there is
design fomo in the community right game
design fomo
right so you look at you look at the
game
right and you just put a screenshot of
of horizon west right
you go oh my god that looks amazing
right if you
tell someone before this can only be
done
on this hardware right then it's this
self value you see
this is what holding out and not cross
generational does
it so you create this this fomo
and now when the truth is revealed
you're hurt because you conceived this
to be some godly thing that could only
happen
in one place whereas the other company
told you
yo that right there this is
cross-generational this is gonna be
played
all these different places and i think
the gaming community
sadly does that to themselves they put
themselves in these positions where they
hype up something
that is just so outrageous to make them
so space
it's a console thing to make themselves
feel value on their perceived purchase
see i made the right decision because
this could only be done on the platform
i
bought you know you know what i i find
funny because i
these this pc master race crap that you
know shout out to
you know this but this is this is these
dudes y'all are not masterful at
anything
oh god wow not a masterpiece gotta catch
you know you know why they're gonna
catch these hands you're gonna catch
these chances half of y'all playing on
1080s right
so if you're playing on the 1080 and
it's a third
you guys are playing on mediocre
consoles right mediocre pcs
right you guys are the equivalent of a
base xbox
right so if i have a 30 80 i'm actually
master race right so how much master
race are you all right
so you're saying based on the numbers in
the wild dude
like everybody got you know with a high
end they think if they
game on a pc their elitist we elitist
why don't you show your specs inside
your box and then and then let's see how
really elites you are listening i'll see
you
to your point right right it's a small
percentage it's just it's for
all of us but all i will say outside
is that i like my pc managed to raise
brothers only because
at least in the xbox ecosystem we could
rock
we got synergy oh you got the cross play
we got the thing we gotta saying like
they all the beauty of this windows 11
stuff
is synergy magic the marriage right
because
in the past it wasn't necessarily there
like oh you could do this but you can't
do this we can't really play together we
can
now it's like yo this vision shout out
to queen sarah you know what i'm saying
she was out there on the stage you know
saying salute
and i love this because now i feel like
yo when cross play comes out
destiny and all this stuff i'm truly
going to play with these people i'm
truly
having that i'm having that fun in
outriders i'm having that fun now right
there it tells me who's cross play cause
i leave my joint open
it tells me who's cross played so if
he's coming from playstation he's coming
from um
pc wherever the hell he's coming from
we're all interacting with each other
and this should have been like this from
behind
right okay and i think microsoft
spearheading
this whole champion this movement for
cross play
that synergy starts and has always
started with microsoft taking that foot
forward
other people were resisting in doing it
and they had to bend the knee
to a superior console i mean uh um
a product the um product which is the
fortnight
a superior uh game software
fortnight may playstation vendor knee
in in that whole thing and transform
that landscape because remember
everybody else was doing it right but
these guys so i think
i i i love the synergy i love where
we're going i think we beat this one
yeah we beat this today so i'll get your
point off and then we roll up no
i know i completely agree i just think
anybody who thinks that playstation
isn't going for that same synergy
is not reading the tea leaves right and
it's just
you're fooling yourself you have to like
if you think if you look at
you know what they're doing with
deviation games and whatever that game
is going to be multiplayer centric
whatever
i think they already talked about the
jade raymond game is going to be some
sort of living game
right i'ma tell you right now i would
not be surprised
if those games are day-and-date pc
releases as well when they come out
because they're multiplayer and we talk
about synergy and we talk about
the expanding the reach of that
ecosystem the way microsoft is doing
right now
playstation has to find a way to do that
and they don't have the same avenue to
do it that microsoft does
how do you do that these multiplayer
centric games that
and i don't know how they're going to
word it jim ryan going to dance around
this one
but it's day and date i'm telling you
these are the games that'll be day and
day
maybe not the maybe not their prestige
triple a
first parties last of us god of war
maybe not day and date but these
multiplayer games that they have in the
pipeline
right trust me okay look it's a good
discussion that's good to say i love
these topics we'll just
try to roll right into this because it's
kind of synergetic with what's going on
and um
yeah just wanted to talk about obviously
shout out to one away dragon i was on
in the dragon's den with the bro you
know what i'm saying said they shot the
pk
we had a good discussion one of the
topics that came up was the um
what you call the fc rdr the super
resolution solved that
you know greatly asked uh lord lord
did i force lord jason ronaldo i love
jason ryan to answer ahead of time it
was one of the highest hit
questions solved it very smoothly very
smooth but yeah
we heard that's out this dlss you know
kind of competitor
and just being able to get a little bit
of more performance out of even all the
way back
you know say it to you old og xbox one
you know console so that
and then i don't know if you guys heard
the um it seems to be like the series
x server blades may be in the wild that
microsoft being officially
said that they've you know adjusted all
the server forms to
switched over from the series i mean
from the 1s to over the series x but
we're still in reports shout out to
clobrell
he had a great uh tweet out in reference
to some of the things he was seeing on
xcloud
he's playing rainbow six he's the 120
frames option they're seeing the
performance bulls shout out to lord jess
quarter window so he was supposed to be
on during these two subjects because he
was going to give him some insight but
he had some things he had to take care
of so salute to jazz but um
yeah we started to see that role right
now so i just want to get your feedback
solver start with you
you know super resolution what you are a
champion of you you were the one that
brought it to our attention and then
obviously the the server blades
potentially being upgraded on xcloud
i mean i think everything they're doing
is
looking for ways to improve the
performance and fidelity
and feel of the xbox experience on
any on whatever platform you choose to
engage with it
um by doing this stuff at the back end
to really
to you know to to to have that
experience be what people want
right i think if there is a barrier to
people hopping onto xcloud and really
giving it a go and playing those games
in that regard
is bandwidth right first and foremost
and then after that is just the
experience of
the the the input lag of how it looks
does it look soupy does
it look like it's smeared in vaseline
you know stuff like that
um and if you fix that stuff on the back
end little by little
all of the stuff on your end that needs
to be that needs to be rectified starts
getting smaller and smaller
and it just comes down to okay how do i
increase my bandwidth
in order to be able to enjoy this stuff
that they've given me on that end
right so for me it's huge it it's huge
and i think again we've used this word
to death today but it's synergy
it is how do you take how do you best
give the best expression of your product
on each of these different platforms
that you're trying to
to get people to engage with it on and
they're doing everything necessary on
each one of these levels
to make sure that you get the best xbox
experience
and you know the fact that the server
blades are going out
it's you know especially as difficult as
it's been just to get xboxes in people's
hands the fact that they're doing this
on this back end to
to really make to xcloud
a much more viable option to more people
i don't think people realize the
long-term goals they have with xcloud
i think people a lot of people it's
coming out now right like
they've seen it now people don't really
even still see it
like i i don't i think i think xcloud
was designed to work with 4g
but it was built on the fact that 5g
and bill still upset as much like yeah
and then so until 5g is rolling out
and it's in its standard i don't think
you're going to see their vision of
xcloud until that day happens
i just tried to get uh 5g wi-fi inside
the house you know we don't have it in
my head
i have a lot of friends that you know is
like the
japan area and stuff and they said
x-cloud works
way better there then yeah yeah yeah
let me i'm sorry so i finished it just
real quick and so
on the the the fidelity effects stuff
right um
you know we talked about you know this
is the first time i've ever seen
first time i've ever seen the secret
sauce actually works right right
and the thing is right now yes let's
talk about how it brings down
obviously image quality is isn't quite
there yet
oh god you're good right like me but no
no but but this is a reality
the thing that makes fidelity effects
special is that it can work
on top of everything else so if you're
running rtx
you can run on top of that it so it
once again synergy it's everywhere
whereas rtx is very localized to what to
those graphics cards all this stuff and
it's free
in conjunction that's free because rtx
is not free
right in the free so to me it's one of
those things that we're gonna get it
it's gonna be in an early state and it's
gonna continue to improve it
and on the console side when you start
getting performance on the car and we've
seen it already
without having to use this when you're
talking about games that have 120 fps
mode
if you really think about when they
started talking to us about the series x
and what it could do
in the beginning there was no talk of
120. 120 came after
i think what you're going to see is
when microsoft like a lot of people
thought it was a joke when microsoft
says
we want to reach 2 billion gamers
because currently how the market is they
can't reach 2 billion gamers
because they they don't have access to
the markets that's only mobile
right and i mean even playstation
doesn't have access to those markets
so their their their goal is like look
like that's why they're opening up stuff
when it comes to
dragon quest uh final fantasy they got
all the final fantasy they're besides
you know the ones that we want like
seven and 16.
uh you know they they're rumored highly
rumored that persona is going to go in
there
so like sure we think that they're
getting these games for our demographic
they are but they're really getting this
this demographic for these mobile
markets that you can't get into
without a mobile presence they don't
accept console markets and
that's what when you're going to start
seeing game pass really pick up is when
xcloud is accessible in these regions
like extremely accessible yeah and
you're going to start seeing
like thousands upon thousands upon
thousands of new subscription
and that's when you're going to really
see the the subscription model go from
like
30 million to like 70 80 million yeah
it's what these people are added into
this subscription service
i think um that that was like the
byproduct of
all these other subscription services
when they hit an app and they got to
that uh
that markets that they couldn't reach
you know normally
that's you see that uptake there um that
fidelity
effect stuff yeah let's go yeah what'd
you see what's going on yeah all right
so i'm watching digital foundry
watching i'm watching digital family due
to breakdown and it was like they showed
native when they showed up
i said okay i can tell you in your
emphasis because
they sitting there saying like they
showing it two screens
and it was like you see there's really
no difference i said no clearly
clearly clearly if that doesn't matter
to me shout out to tco we had a chance
to watch your television
yesterday um stupid while we were eating
and i do realize there's a complete
difference
i really i saw you up close i saw you
with your best life why are you
comparing those
bugs
and they happen to have a tcl which was
hilarious which was hilarious
absolutely hilarious in my dining
experience they were present
[Laughter]
and then i feel you know it is it's
adequate
it's adequate and what i saw there
in the fidelity fx i have to i have to
scale back
my expectations of it okay because what
i was explaining that
you won't be able to tell the difference
from native
to bs brother sees the difference
but again that allows you to have more
horsepower
more uh cpu power to do other things to
power the world in different ways
that you don't need to max out and have
uh 8k
textures and stuff like so i understand
where we're going with it it's in its
infancy
and truly later on with different
iterations of it it will reach its apex
but at this moment in time it is
adequate for what they want but that's
freeing
up the horsepower and the cpu power to
do those
unimaginable things that we are begging
for those
transformative things they're no longer
tied to
uh sizes of textures which eats
up huge amounts of ram which takes up
a huge amounts of cpu power you can
change that into uh
the cpu power of ai ai is
from what i'm hearing from all these new
developers and all these developers that
we have
is where they want to change uh going
forward
in uh uh this new generation that we're
in now
the current generation we're in the
current generation we're not in next
this is current generation now
so the ai i see we're going to see it as
a huge difference because
remember when we was playing metal gear
and they were doing things that
we we was like wow look at the patterns
on the dudes they change their patterns
particularly to certain things that
happen in the the ecosystem
i think i think that is where we're
going to see a dramatic change
you know where really where it's really
going to shine i think even in this
infant state
is little man yo god damn it song
i like to rock with it you're good i i
love you because you always
give your point with your jokes we are
the same way
i think it's the biggest benefit because
right now they're talking about
1080p is kind of the baseline where you
can still
you'll it will give you that resolution
internally and be able to bump up what
it can do
on the um in terms of graphical effects
in terms of frame rate whatever the case
may
be a little man emoji yo
yeah just have them you know yeah
with like a little series
up when i got a little man and he was
like what where's this little bad thing
i think neil spark asked me i was a kid
came up with that
yeah but i listen man
that little machine does a lot of
awesome stuff okay we got to do it yeah
we got to eat
that little machine punches above his
weight already yeah
and to give it this this shot in the arm
it's crazy i'm gonna tell you right now
yo bro yo yo yo yo yo listen let me let
me jump in because uh shout out to again
i see what i wait up in there
had a fantastic discussion on the
dragon's den
yo subscribe my brother one away dragons
tv he's really putting it in man i
really like
i enjoyed myself there shout out to pk
he was really dropping some knowledge
on this whole you know super resolution
stuff and again the games haven't
implemented it just yet but the fact
that they
are talking about it now this is
something i've seen again lord jay
serrano who was up in the realm
would solve acid this was something
super excited about it you know what i
mean and
i think like king said anything to me
that you get to eke out more performance
excites me especially early in the
generation yes you know what i'm saying
because the
sbi's you know dev kits tools all this
stuff you're still learning as you go
right you're still
maximizing so they hear this stuff to
see the excitement
that they're having about it is really
cool anything that where
you get more overhead to other things
like and you get good characters and and
it being real
and tangible yes i mean you guys know
how excited i was the xbox one
remember that look at the cloud what was
your bad day
mr x media would come out he had like a
vlog we'd be like y'all like 100 times
the performance like
it's truly five times more powerful than
that with the cloud computation that i
wanted to believe
i would have wanted to believe and then
theory yeah and
it was all out the window because when
you tried to actually play
that the system exploded for it to be
real and tangible like i said even in
its infancy and it's not super
impressive in that way to kingwood it's
like oh my god it's game changing right
now
but it's something that is tangible and
you know they're going to iterate on it
the secret sauce is actually real
shout out to parents i know we still
rolling brothers
yes but it's it's exciting tech man i
love this stuff i
i get excited because no disrespect to
the last generation right
but it's just like you know we felt they
came in a little underbaked you know
what i mean
like i like those generations like the
360 when you're like yo they're coming
in on
with people i love when a generation
starts and it's
already at the apex with what's current
in the pc space and now you can iterate
now you can do these techniques and
doing all the stuff and then we talked
about
you know a prior topic before with
windows 11 it's just
shaping up to this fun little generation
of synergy with tech
and then these advancements that could
push it you know even further beyond
that
right and the last point i'll say is you
know we all
as much as we were championing ray
tracing right
the reality hit when we like damn you
look at all that before yeah this is a
performance
like damn that performance hit i don't
know if i want ray tracer with all
you bringing your frames down so it's
just it's just
cool man i love this type of stuff i
know sof you love it
yeah you always ask these type of
questions king you know we get excited
and i got i'm jaded to it yeah i'm not
gonna lie i'm jaded to it because i'm so
sick and tired of
you know when somebody comes out and
tell you put your ears in the box
you know we're gonna do something wants
the pure experience
yeah i'm so sick and tired of the lies
so to actually see it being implemented
and being shown
yes don't talk about it talk about it do
it right now right and
and these dudes have been about it maybe
it didn't reach my level of expectation
yet but the possibilities of
what has been shown right will reach
those expectations that i do have so
right now so question for y'all
with all this stuff being a reality
right on
on all ends right do you i see a mid gen
refresh at any point
or we're not getting at this yet i don't
think so not for the xbox and
not for the xbox in the series that's
and i don't think so i don't think so
yeah
specifically there yeah i don't i don't
think so because like you mentioned cog
like you mentioned like
honestly the xbox one generation started
three years late
yes that that generation should have
started in 2010.
yeah they may be able to rock these
boxes out for a while um
anyway but like especially the um
the series s and um that shout shot a
little man because
i i think that's the trojan horse for a
lot of these markets i i feel that
it might be yeah i think eventually you
know as
for people who either are just in a
playstation or nintendo ecosystem only
you know that might be the first choice
and then again if you're able to get
this performance you're able to do these
things with the series s
right with these techniques and it's
still on par with a lot of what's going
on with with the bigger consoles i think
it becomes an attractive model
especially with game pass and
that's that yeah okay i just i just want
to say that okay
now for what's a rarely available little
man is the benefit of
hardware in place right what has been
talked about in silence uh
you know like as far as the fire stick
thing
i think that is uh that's the real
trojan horse to get into your house if i
could pick up a controller and
uh the fire stick thing and just you
know like plugging it around that that's
another one yeah
and you know financially from that
standpoint and that's where
the super sampling and you know the
fidelity effects and all that other
stuff
comes into play and gives that boost but
from a native
console hardware space i think little
man is just like you said
uh is is that trojan horse in that space
i believe yeah
that makes sense the last point i'll
make is i just want to touch on it is
xcloud because i
really love hearing that those series
exploits are going to come out because
oh they're doing that already yeah like
that excites me because again
seeing that that when you see that
imperceptible latency
that's what makes it a game changer
that's what makes it okay
i can actually do this and this is
viable
in a space now for some we get it and
they're not gonna want it
again it's an option but for some they
are gonna do it and if you notice
if you look at the game pass list
recently you'll see
more xbox pc and cloud
you're starting to see the and cloud on
a lot of these game pass or the month
games that get announced
they're starting to impress shout out to
yakuza like a dragon shot to the cops
they're excited
but there's a lot of things going on
where it's like yo
you're seeing the cloud more and this is
something they want to implement
all they're doing is going to pick up
the new consoles you know you have to
have police escorts when you go
because you know man baby
playstation 5's at walmart
[Applause]
you gotta get there
that's all i got on this giant you know
what i'm saying shout out what jesus
said yes serious that's caused too much
with the story
yeah you know what you do sell gene look
out the lord's gamer.net in the building
just get that
get that little arm that caddy that usb
3.0 caddy until you're ready
but what i did is i when i got little
man i was able to
uh take my um xbox one x to uh again on
gamestop
two hundred dollars credit baby so i was
able to get me another expansion card
for philippines yes that is definitely
necessary
it has been a game changer for me the
fact that you know they they had the
first ice
shout out to jason ryan on the team they
have the foresight to have a ssd
uh expansion available at launch
and and that i have all this wonderful
fast memory it's this is changing you
know quick resume
shout out to the the most powerful
most stable most equipped console in the
business
in generations too oh god that keeps
going real though
we're actually gonna end kind of early
today which is good so
unless you want to do this you want to
do the pole super chat you wouldn't do a
song let me let me run through these
super chat i don't think it's that many
all right come on a second
super chats that i pull we get about
here and we got
hold up today
right now it should be right now i'll
check it out uh with the release date
of halo infinite being committed to a
holiday
release window when do you think halo
infinite should release
the choices are a september or october
let halo breathe and keep it separate
from forza horizon 5.
b november coincide with halo
anniversary date
for a big holiday splash or c
i don't care but they best stay away
from big cod
out in these gaming streets
that is the question please rock the
vote when it goes
up on ilp twitter this week later i
don't actually know twitter i should
actually
gaming.net that should be up now so
check that out
but yeah that is the question rock that
out solved are we ready to get these
super chats
hashtag i don't care about no k c o d
yeah
divo
[Applause]
all right we got natra brown 10 super
chat great shows always gentlemen great
listening while trucking down the road
be safe or natural no doubt
man loves see we giving that four-hour
love dude yeah yeah
make the time go by quickly exactly then
we got clutch man five dollar super chat
i can smell it now wait i
he put this again hold on yeah
okay drawn jt five dollars super chat
you guys are the best you make my day i
listen to you guys rdx podcast and
double barrel gaming all
family thank you so much damn fam shout
out to the artix how the deal of game in
the crows okay
you know what i'm saying of course then
we got flame oh i'm sorry
the double barrel boom man the hardest
working man in the back happy
anniversary happy anniversary shot
he's just family salute then we got
flame five dollars so we checked
against that flame we didn't get to ask
him is there any extra chest in the
balls of glass will he ever
[Laughter]
i'm not sure i'm not sure his wife
nothing is oh then we got rodella five
five dollar super chat
joey bats made me send the super chat he
said show some respects all right all
right
okay okay we're glad to get the goons
because they've been trying yeah yeah
you're trying to shake us
then we got abel asic with the one
dollar super chat thank you so much
brother you can say something just
please say something there we go
all right raiden blade five pound super
chat i have said this before microsoft
wants xbox to be a trillion dollar
company too
yeah it feels like they really want xbox
to shine
in parallel with what they're doing like
it's it's it's amazing to see
then we got gerald mack five dollars of
a chat phil dominus maximus aurelius
spencer
yes sir influence is felt through
microsoft now a different game
yes his influence is felt everywhere now
this is why they have been walking
around with bodyguards all the time
and after shout out to again grg i said
i honestly in the long term
i see phil that's the head of microsoft
whoa
i see it i see it yeah
i see it yeah um then we got raiden
blade
two pound super chat phil de satya
microsoft must be all in
satya we aim satya odin
a dollar yeah yeah odin
then we got brad with the two dollar
super chat being messy pc mastery
show your specs just show your specs
let's see let's see
let's see if it's really bench pressing
or not you're gonna get bravo here but
it's been a while she's been in the
realm
[Laughter]
awesome show great halo insight and
great guest
iop on fire as usual congratulations on
the big moves this week for iop as a
registered company thank you
oh thank you brother yes yes then we
have
[ __ ] 8127 five dollars in the chat
photogrammetry
desert car xbox hit horizon five that
the 2019 game awards console reveal xbox
sent it hints out for a long time
yeah they they send out a lot of hits
for stuff that you just don't see
um and i love that you know it's like an
arg you just
have to figure stuff out then we got
[ __ ] once again pop dollars with chat
phil spencer can dribble a bowling ball
on the seventh day
god rested and phil took over his tears
cure
cancer too bad he never cries oh my god
we need a book of acts at the end of the
day he was out of control
you sir definitely have so far uh
super chat today to the show yeah that's
the shirt
that we got post up five dollars every
time
i called them sony dudes out on these
amazing pcs and they
and they say they have on twitter and
they didn't show up yeah a lot of people
they like to make the pc argument and
just done you know they don't have that
show your sex yeah yeah that's my whole
thing right now
what's inside your box paul
and we got flame two dollar super chat
gonna need an emote for that synergy
soon talking a lot of synergy today
yes hold on now we got a couple so let
me go back a little bit
okay we got clutch man five dollars with
a chat
2018 sony how did you get the extra boot
space in the building for e3 microsoft i
bought the building
[Laughter]
then we got one bad mother five dollars
in the chat another sunday another
incredible interview and discussion
by the way finish mass effect for the
first time and me3 is the best one
some people say that a lot of they play
people say that first time
that's facts oh here
[Laughter]
the five dollar super chat haven't seen
much about the 20th anniversary of xbox
or halo from microsoft yet
do you think something is coming yeah
halo infinite is coming that's what's
coming yes sir
we had it on today mm-hmm then we got
mariano five dollars congrats lords on
all the big moves
much more success to you all immortality
take it
it's yours that's real lordly talking
yeah that's what's up i know what he
talked about then we got excuse me have
a drink because i feel like i've
swallowed razor blades
that's nice yeah runaway dragons tv five
dollars will be chat i'm giving people
ptsd and halo this holiday be afraid
awesome job today as usual my brothers
are lit little man pulling weight
no facts
[Laughter]
but anyway so we got that man let's rap
oh our attic is still there you're
eating whatever
but uh we still outro sir i'm i'm not
eating oh okay lord where can you find
people find you what you got going on
sir
you can find me on twitter lore addict
iop you can find me on uh
youtube at gaming addict uh i the
content's been a little bit lack it's
going to be a remedy here in the next
couple days
uh keep in mind on the sixth of next
month we will be streaming sea of
thieves
uh so i'm pretty sure you guys are gonna
enjoy that a lot of fun
yeah yeah yeah i'm
with the lords yes we need that really
too
you know
yes so uh well that will be happening on
the sixth i think i think that's the day
we uh
agreed to yes uh we will be doing the
new content for that
so uh keep keep an eye on for that
and uh that's that's all folks that's
all folks no doubt yeah
lord solve my man what do we got going
on we're gonna fight before you
you know you can find me lois i have iop
on twitter bx sovereign on psn
xbox live i'm gonna speak a little
slowly because again like i said i feel
my my throat's killing me paul's voice
um
yesterday was yesterday was a special
and emotional day for us
um just because it's
it's the culmination of step one of a
journey that started
four years ago at this point pretty much
officially
um and i just i couldn't be happier
prouder of my brothers
was what's happened today and what
what's to come
um i never never would have thought
shout out to king for all king having
the foresight having the belief
oh cog is the one that that goes out
there and enacts it
and i'm the i'm the one that needs to i
need to see the road ahead
and i and it's funny because we've
always been that way i think
and then no no addict addict excuse me
my apologies attic wasn't there
yesterday so i apologize but
attic is the dude that he understands
these twitter streets he understands
he understands how to machinate and move
and attic behind the scenes
is passionate and tenacious and a lot of
this stuff that happens behind the
scenes is because addict is in there
talking to people
and i i've never seen somebody so
passionate to go out there and just
really
get these interviews get this stuff
happen
yeah this is you know again it's a
culmination of a lot of work if anything
i'm gonna i and these guys know
i wish i could be more involved on the
day-to-day stuff because my day-to-day
is crazy but i appreciate being a part
of this
um and and sky's the limits i love y'all
sky's the limits i'm so happy where we
at and i can't even imagine
to see where we're going lord
king wait fine people got going on for
you sir
[Music]
i sat back yesterday um yeah yeah i was
late uh attic was there first
i think it was their first paperwork in
digital form
addict was there first and um sovereign
pulled up
and i left my house completely early and
shout out to
jersey i hate you jersey jersey with
your traffic for no
absolute reason under the sun leaving it
took me an hour and a half to get home
um but
likes like okay so being cursed with
vision is is hard
right being cursed with vision allows
you to see things ahead of the time
before it happens i know you guys you
know
like to make jokes that uh yeah uh
king of prophet xbox and stuff like that
but being cursed with vision
allows you to see things before it
happens and some people don't believe
you
or some people don't get it at that
point in time but it's going to happen
in
fruition later on and when it does come
to pass
you're not really excited as much as
those people that is happening because
it's happening in real time for them
you already were present there at that
moment
but seeing
my brother's excitement um seeing
addict's hard work way before the
excitement even hit because he did it
on monday of that week when he had other
stuff that he was doing and he made sure
that he took care of his stuff
first business right um
seeing their excitement knowing that we
made it to this place and then you
you sign off on things and to seeing the
ladies excitement too
she was excited too and then she brought
her friend over to
to cheer into the excitement yeah you
know other things
um what's funny is when i went to my
thing
the individual that was working was like
well i don't think i need to copy any of
your stuff and i was like
i was thinking myself you better not
need to copy any of my stuff
because i am not driving another hour
and a half
and it calls me he calls me he's like
look he's saying that he doesn't need
that i'm like you know what give it to
him anyway yeah make sure
anyway he's like he's like well they
don't really like us sending
people stuff like that so i don't think
i need it and i think myself
you better not need it we at that point
now or
i was at that point where i'm
comfortable with you having my stuff in
your desk if i don't
come back but but
we here yeah we're here now we here when
we had 10 people in the chat
to when we have how many people showed
up today
and we here because of you guys we push
because of you guys we do
because of you guys and and and also we
actually really love each other yeah
you know so from the hard work from cog
and the hard work from attic and the
hard work from
south suburbs i like to tell you he
doesn't do hard work that he does he do
yeah all right he really does um
everybody's pulling their weight in all
aspects of their strengths right we all
have different strengths so we don't
expect somebody to do something that
that's not their strength
but i love you guys i just really wanted
to say that because
it was very special and to see the
response from your
tweet yeah yeah all right and
i gotta give a shout out to you know
attic again mm-hmm
i saw somebody say something that don't
normally ever speak and annika was like
yeah you can talk to me later you can
talk to me
in the dean and i'm pretty sure he went
right after yeah and kahala that uh old
boy there
but i also do addict has a level of ocd
that he will complete
whatever his task is and a lot of these
big interviews
are attributed to uh in conjunction with
cog but attributed to attic i'm glad you
know
um because he does a lot of the leg work
let me jump in because that is very
important and um i know i probably don't
want me to say this but i'm gonna say it
and i
you know look we all we all
love each other and part of being a team
you know what i'm saying is making sure
everyone is respected for their
contribution
and i feel like you know my brother
doesn't get enough
let's be an addict as far as his
contribution to iron lord's podcast
i love him like a brother he's cool with
being in the background reserve but
you know when i see a lot of people say
hey you know they want cog and they want
king or whatever that's cool
but don't eliminate my bro from these
podcasts and these conversations
because he is a vital part of ireland's
podcast
a lot of these big interviews we get
addict is directly responsible
for making them happen so i just wanted
to say that publicly because i don't
think i've ever said it
you know what i'm saying like i i really
like the respect
given to my brother as well we are a
unit we are a team
you know me and him started this edition
he came to me with it i wasn't a
podcaster i wasn't a youtuber i wasn't
into
i'm an old dude that talked my talk and
party chat
and that's when i was content on doing
that and he know that
knows me like this would have ended it
at any time for me because i just didn't
have that passion that he had
until he brought me into this world and
then i'm like okay
i kind of like it and then you get your
introducings and you get you all the
goofy stuff that i like to do
so salute to that that's number one you
know i'm saying solve
obviously was the first guest so to
speak you know i said
you know you know the history you know
what we've done you know i'm saying
sister third grade brother you know what
i'm saying this is double dragon in the
crib you know what i mean yeah and all
that so
just to see him and his insight and i
love when people ask for his insight and
really his personality and kings
start to see his personality truly shine
because we know him
and king i gotta admit bro like i love
you because
you truly see things way ahead of
everyone
and you would tell me cog i see us we
gonna be
the beaches we gonna be sipping on the
books and i'm like
chill bro we got like 10.
but you know what it is he didn't
realize certain things that i would do
and they say why are you giving out 200
shirts why
why are you spending so much money on
doing this why are you why are you doing
this
i see he see it he see he do he do
what was funny is i remember when he uh
when we printed that like what those
thousand shirts at e3
i remember i was i was talking to you
guys in the chat i was like i was like
we don't even have a thousand live views
cuz yo all these [ __ ] bro they weren't
cheap
we spent so much money out of our pocket
king was
so adamant i know
my apologies guys i'm listening but i
have a small emergency okay
i'm here i'm here that was way before we
made money off the podcast
bro it's just to see the vision and i'll
never forget
when you know when it really hit for me
king when right you made us do
and miss be an addict talking to the
back like i'm handing out shirts
everybody
but you go to e3 and we all
decked out we got our joints and seeing
the response and seeing people come up
and seeing developers like yo y'all got
to stop by our booth cause we wouldn't
like i want so it's just to see you know
that whole cultivate
and and and to now make it official you
know and to be
an llc to be a corporation and be a you
know to be something that we're all
pulling together an
entity is super cool to see the love
from that tweet which again me and adam
was like wow this is really
yeah go over i got it and you know
that's one of the reasons that we're
always so like you know down to earth
when
it comes to like guesting on smaller
shows because
back when we were small for every one
big guest we had we had five people
ghost underneath that was like
yeah you know we always had that mindset
it's like look like i don't care how big
we get like we're never going to forget
the little guy we're never going to
forget where we came from
because a lot of these people like they
they almost impossible to get a hold of
yeah that's real obviously with the
because of the community because of how
big we've gotten like
the big guests that we've gotten is all
because of you guys
because you guys give us something that
we need to get them it's called
statistics we need viewership and with
with that viewership you guys have gave
us a
uh a card that we can go to people like
look
we have five to eight hundred live
viewers they can put you to be your live
viewers but you gotta come on
and i'm not saying and none of these
people came on for you know any kind of
cloud or anything like that but it does
help yeah and shout out to the rome we
gotta shout the rum out because
the the undying those guys are great
they're just uh i've never seen a
community like this like we one time we
couldn't end the show because the super
chats kept
coming in you know and then also i shout
out the realm because i've seen them
reach out to bigger guests and say you
guys need to be on ilb
you know and something has happened as a
result because of you because of the
realm the round pulling up saying yo
so thank y'all you know i want to take
one more person
lord rick hogue shout out to rick holt
for um helping us
finalize division you know if anybody is
looking i got to plug them because if
anybody
is looking to take their whole situation
to the next level if you want to do an
llc whole
law is in his bag man yes really he
treated us with care and respect
no finessing straight transparency
you know and for content creators
someone who understands lawyers that
actually understand what youtube is and
the whole thing shout out to someone who
just cop the merch shout out to reggie
reggie mobile now i've got that classic
t i see you salute
muslim god bless but salute the holy law
man please like again
subscribe to him very knowledgeable guy
but also on his business since you know
if he he does these type of acquisitions
so i got to plug him
if anybody is interested in uh the llc
game but
king attica let you finish yeah we're
just going to grab these super jabs
keep in mind when it's come to you know
the
we've always had you guys at the center
of everything when we talk about
you know the patreon stuff the member
stuff we always want to make sure we
don't try to lock too much stuff behind
if anything we really don't like
anything behind paywall
because at the end of the day we we
value
giving you guys more content to watch
than we value locking content behind
stuff
so and we've always had that at the
center of everything some stuff you
might get a little
sooner like you know we do a little bit
of stuff for the members but
what i like is that you guys support
just support us like
we don't really got nothing behind that
member stuff but you guys
enjoy the stuff we get and and we
we're always appreciative of that well
you're gonna have a lot more with these
live shows
is the streets our bread and butter is
being with the people
our bread and butter is going to these
shows so kovit hit us hard too
um but when we we are going to be right
back at it so the king is about to go
get his shots this week
you know so i could be up to date with
all my um vaccinations
like a puppy um and um
right back to these streets right back
to the people right back to being
in the midst of the crowds having
conversations talking to these
developers getting these interviews
being at the heart in the center of what
makes us go
forward bringing you the stuff that you
want to see
and stuff that you want to hear whether
you like it or not
fast good job y'all blow weight about
addict
because yes real quick
and keep in mind like i know we've had a
lot of like high tier we ain't even done
like oh no
we still have a lot of like it's got to
the point
like i'll just tell you guys we're
booked to like august september yeah
like
right we have to we have to push like
people back
sometimes big people back like sometimes
i have to talk to someone like
yeah we could be like yo i'll get you
like august right i think it's the 15th
yeah yeah exactly and then it it's crazy
to be you have to tell people that like
it's like
who are you to be telling me yeah right
yeah but
listen it's it's no matter how big no
matter how small your spot is just
small too don't think it's just going to
be only oh yeah this is always going to
be the same way it's been mad if
you show us love and you out there
working hard you're going to make your
way to the realm that is for sure
um listen yeah because i
i realized that because of the because
of the relationship that that cog and
king and i have for so many years
i know it's got to be difficult for alec
to be like where where do i fit in here
and the reality of it is that you are so
integral to
all of this you have no idea bro
like [ __ ] you kind of are you're the
baseline
like cox said you brought him into into
a world that he he had no intentions of
going in
what's so whatever who's gonna sit here
for three hours listen to someone talk
and stream like
it made no sense to me yeah and i'm like
yeah
exactly i never started listening to the
podcast until after cog
on podcast look man you need to start
listening to these things and i'm like
and i'm like who who told you about all
this stuff he's like this chaotic that i
play games with and i'm just like that i
tricked him in the game
yeah and and and to me
i just i want you to realize that
how much you mean to us and how much you
mean to this
and it in no way shape or form does any
of this happen without
you and i i can't do a quarter of the
things that you do
i don't know what was deciding
real quick side note side side side
little joint
yo me and attic is a different story
than in this podcast stuff me and addict
was playing destiny together
he had a dude that i could not stand i
was gonna drive to this dude house and
beat him up cause he's barbering at it
so listen my love for this dude is crazy
different is this because it wasn't had
nothing to do
it had everything to do i think it was
before the podcast
it was it was this is my destiny dude
stop messing with him
we just we have trust in each other yeah
like like what
when i went to do the stuff for you know
our llc the due straight was like yo
you know keep in mind yeah anytime any
of these these guys can shine
at any time i was like i wouldn't be
here if i didn't trust them like
exactly yeah man beautiful day beautiful
day that's all i got to say
we appreciate all you do fellas love to
iop
don't turn out like the beatles once you
guys brought to one million nah
i think i think that's the thing with us
it's like i'm ringo it is always
fantastic
it is family first always
so i think you guys know that about it
that kind of got me sad yesterday yeah
when i was driving but then it made me
happy because it was raining that's when
i got sad and then the sun came out and
rod told me
he's up there looking at me he's so
proud he he told me from
day one when we started ilp he was just
like bro
y'all got it like this is something
special shout out to the anchor man also
too
busy and anchor man with two people that
really gave us the confidence to say yo
what y'all have is special
just listen to the on party chats and
just what y'all do and now to see the
big screen so to speak people hear us
yeah and keep in mind i do want to state
something that
i i get you i do the patreon stuff and
the community stuff and i
a few of you have voiced your your
your thing about the emotes uh the
emails that's in the chat yeah
i don't know if you guys know this but
how the emotes work is after we get a
certain amount of members
right they unlock another another one
and i've had probably three or four
people a week asked can we get this one
on like we can get that one on there
i will tell you right now we need four
more members for another emo
i'm the one that do the pose adequate
always comes in second but it's always
one that beats it but
we gotta add a little red to the big
man somebody finagling the numbers
[Music]
proud and happy for you guys and your
success high key a big inspiration to
keep me
and moves and moves i make and i want to
make
keep grinding thank you alvin who just
joined the room
emojis
we need three more now and we got wait
so we got leonard herrera
welcome to the put the crust in the chat
for leonard herrera i guess you guys
read that out already no no you did then
we got smitty smith 10
super chat i said once and i'll say it
again they will make room for iop
the attic show log net kos the last word
and dcx
salute to the lord's the book of the
house smitty smith the originator of
book of
then we got philly eagle five dollar
super chat i support
family iop is family thank you
got a chance to probably take them to
the party chat being king good dude yes
sir salute
absolutely and then we got gaming forte
five dollar super chat
y'all about to make added cry but for
real addict is one of the most genuine
people i know
might piss me off but still my
[Laughter]
then we got tony briar five dollars you
have austin creed and sarah bond coming
soon
manifested
then we got welcome lord alvin to the
realm put the crest in the chat for lord
alvin yes sir
no doubt then we got suicide kings five
dollar super chat
putting in my dollars passing the plate
to the right hashtag every community
hashtag
tcl's revenge
since rk do it we just need two more now
it just jumped in yeah i'll refresh it
i think we need one more okay welcome to
the realm lord
arcade arcade 4247 put the crown on the
door
then we gotta just gonna show up bro
raiden blade
two pound super attack two more members
needed let's go then we got
hare keith shania welcome to the realm
lord
of the rings no doubt thank you and we
are
done done we see you guys next week and
more fun stuff
playing good things going on cannot wait
great interviews three four three so
patrick ran the whole team
we are out of here until next week peace
you guys stick around
[Music]
are we back we're back yeah right
yo still
[Applause]
i'll put up the the the pose sometime
today or tomorrow
please link me in that tweet because my
my my retweet guys are crazy
so uh we i want that poll i want that
part little man
love y'all
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]